right on time the show is gonna get set
to start here with me of course his name
is Aman Hamilton and he currently boasts
the scariest beard in chess on his way
to the Grandmaster title Aman how
excited are you for the two guys we see
right above us as they eagerly await
these games to get started hi Danny and
hi everybody
yeah it's good to be here Danny this is
gonna be interesting because it's one of
those sort of on paper two mismatched we
have Geoffrey kind of a clear underdog
but those those are often the most
interesting matches that people kind of
cheer for the underdog and you know
anything that he does is gonna be better
than expected and some people sighs so
really looking forward and Mac seems got
a bit of a beard so maybe he gets to my
bias does he he's working on that
d'Artagnan look-alike he's working on it
and I think he's I think he's he's
halfway there but you know I agree with
you I the last match that we covered
with Yifan versus Caruana we saw that
you know she's stuck with him and it was
I think closer than a lot of people
expected for really the first half of
the match as the time controls got
faster Fabiana was able to separate
himself I don't know that it's gonna be
the same thing today as Geoffrey is much
more comfortable playing online Blitzen
bullet we see him regularly on chess
calm right him on I mean he he's played
in many title Tuesday's that's actually
how he qualified and got here let's
remind people of that that originally of
course the you know the the start trying
to trying to pull up pull up that scene
here but okay reminding people about the
format right now of course it's 5:00 to
blitz 3:00 to blitz and then we move
into the bullet but originally Maxime
didn't know who he was gonna play
Geoffrey qualified to be the one in this
match and of course the big prize
everybody knows is not even necessarily
the the money on the line today but
really who's gonna move on into the
later rounds the winner of this matchup
will be taking on Sasha Grichuk so
certainly it only gets more intense from
here and and I think we're pretty much
ready so I'm gonna I'm gonna go ahead
and give the give the staff the cue to
go and the players seem ready yep game
on to see them on here
game on right we are started yeah I see
the game live right now the first five -
game and as you can see the ratings are
actually extremely evenly matched
because like you said Geoffrey's a super
regular player in just online blitz
blitz chess titled Tuesday's and
everything so he's he's not really a
reading underdog at all right the
underdog was given white in the first
game here and we have a g3 looking
Benoni don't you play the Benoni amman
that's that's a fairly insulting action
I think the baloney III yeah I feel like
I've made fun of you for the Bologna
before am i confusing my god I played
them I played the Bangko that's the only
Cisco just be opening that I would I
play but around the Benoni has its
moments I'll say this is one particular
example where I actually have played the
Pannonia against this and that's the g3
system I think most top players Danny
consider this to be very harmless system
and there's been a lot of recent games
where black is definitely choosing to
avoid the main lines of the benoni but
definitely go for against this g3
because it's supposed to be quite
harmless away so as we switch over to
the analysis board then maybe you can
tell me why is that exactly why why is
it that that that's the case in regards
to the g3 system not being as dangerous
as say the more the more aggressive
systems where you see white established
pawns on e4 and f4 is it just because
the bishop on this diagonal is
positionally blocked by the pawn on d5
and so you're not gonna get those really
aggressive center positions for white
yeah well a lot of it has to do with the
fact that black has as you can see from
this position the opportunity to gain
quick control of the e4 square so
sometimes that involves a 94 move very
quickly rook takes e4 e to pawn starts
to hang but really I think it's that
there's nothing that black has to be
really concerned about the e5 square is
a lot more accessible with that Bishop
sitting on f4 there's no pawn f4 you
have to play h3 f4 all these moves to
prepare central advances so black kind
of has a lot of time to play with which
usually in the independent like you're
mentioning usually there's like a big
pawn storm or just the e5 threat always
throw a concern devote but here blacks
actually you know easy will able to
waste
Bishop's f5 and Bishop back to c8 and we
may and we may actually see a little a
little repeat or tickle here I don't
know that Maxime would be happy with a
draw given he's a big favor but then
again he's black in the first game and I
think he's gonna ask Geoffrey what his
intentions are
maybe Geoffrey says you know what I'm
not happy with the g3 system either and
we might get a result in the books
faster than we normally do here if the
next scene plays the move Bishop a5 but
that's it here he goes
it's funny that he's doing that cuz it's
almost like he's teasing him he's saying
you know what I can play the benoni and
and just take a draw as black and then
take the white pieces that's you know
that's that's more than enough
I remember Geoffrey played in the st.
Louis and he actually had a disaster
game in the Benoni
the g3 benoni against sandro Morocco
from Argentina uh-huh and and I don't
know if he's maybe Maxine is kind of
tuned into that and said you know I'm
gonna target that system right off the
bat and perhaps Geoffrey didn't expect
that and and he's maybe happy with the
draw because he wasn't sure what what
was gonna happen next
yeah interesting well we'll see if that
becomes a a thing that repeats itself
but as we move over to the score as
weakens everyone can see we have the the
first result in the books only about
five minutes really even maybe less than
that off off the total game clock and
now we have our first Nidal Sicilian
everybody knows Maxime as being the big
at least in terms of the elite players
being the knight or specialist but
knowing Geoffrey for a long time in the
American circuit he also has pretty much
never played any other Sicilian besides
the night or if in serious tournament
play as far as I know so this could be a
knight or Sicilian battle today a month
yeah this is the first night off but
it's definitely not not that last year
we see Geoffrey just whip up this Queen
b6 Queen takes b2 and believe me that's
not something you do without some type
of preparation here Knight takes e5 well
this is like some deep stuff yeah there
they are both busting out the theory
buckle up if you're a high-level
Sicilian player cuz you might actually
want to take notes of these games in
this match
okay the threat here is Queen takes e5
check because the pawn is pinned to the
king everybody this is wild
I mean this
from from an elite standpoint this is
both of these guys are playing really
fast and I'm not sure if Maxine has been
the one to really hit Jeffrey with the
last surprise so to speak but like you
said he's threatening Queen takes e5
Queen d6 always hanging if the black
Queen knows f-4e five are coming into
position and white is gonna castle play
f4 bishop f3 e5 and yep it's I mean it's
a lot of threats to look at but when
someone at Maxine's level especially
since you know he plays the knight or
fourth black when he plays something
like this so quickly that's gotta be
intimidating yeah absolutely and
Geoffrey has gone into the think tank
for the first time and just showing a
little bit of the the line that you kind
of mentioned there so everyone can see
that this is a this is a very very
dangerous attack coming against the
black king especially if white is able
to establish me v and kind of gang up on
the d6 pawn but okay I mean White's down
a piece right if we do the math let's
not forget that a sacrifice was made in
order to get into this position so
normally with prep at this level Amon I
mean obviously I think that where the
joke is always that if both sides play
perfectly according to the Injuns prep
it's gonna be a draw but you know in a
practical game when you really put the
pressure on your opponent you kind of
rather have white here just from the
perspective that just look at the time
right Geoffrey is clearly on his own now
time ticking and Maxime has more time
than he started the game with ya know
this is also shock value moves sometimes
people will always make the argument
that upon has a value that you can
equate Stein in right blitz chess right
and here I don't know what the value is
but I'm sure he's he's surpassed a few
pawns already because he's got almost
double the time of Geoffrey here and
yeah the whole point of good preparation
at at the top level is you can hardly
find moves that actually just force a
win that are completely unheard of ryos
would be some serious theoretical
novelties but often you can just find
the move that makes it the most
difficult for the opponent to find the
draw because often you can tell yourself
as black like all right this is a crazy
sac but if I was a computer that'd be a
draw here somewhere so it's that's try
to buckle down and find him whether he
could find a force win or not he
certainly knows how to find the snacks
maxime continues to just chop away at
whatever the smorgasbord he's got an
apple going and we know the drill here
with Maxine whenever he played in last
year's speech Chess Championship
formerly the grandmaster blitz battles
but funny stuff Geoffrey focused here
though right I mean obviously I think
what you described is right it's his
position that he's up a piece but he's
got a lot to worry about here we've
already highlighted the immediate threat
and I don't know I mean maybe maybe the
knight on e5 should go back to d7 to
avoid this thing you said worth an F my
goes to d7 white then gets f4 with tempo
right it depends I think if Geoffrey is
planning on sacking the the knight back
with like you know maybe move like
Knight ft-7 f4 I'm just trying to leave
that knight on e5 right but but he as
soon as as soon as you do that you have
to understand that white just has the
two bishops and you know he's clearly
clearly done well out of the opening so
Geoffrey like I mean he'd pretty much
use all his time there I think he's
trying a little too hard to try to
understand this this sacrifice yeah yeah
it seems like a bit much because now I
mean regardless of him getting at a
danger I think the time is is too much
and why it's gonna cement that bishop on
the d6 square with moves like c5 and E 5
and with g7 hanging the position here
probably Castle we're coming to see one
as well this looks quite impressive at
least two to start off so I think the
main thing here Dani is just the time no
you're right I think that the more you
look at the position actually Geoffrey
has sort of I mean he's coordinated
right he's got the rook on d8 he's got
the bishop on e6 okay g7 is hanging but
if you if you took away the time here
you'd be much more unclear to say all
right how is white gonna justify the
piece sacrifice right but you know given
the fact that he's you know about to go
under a minute it makes you like white
even more the rook comes to d1 everybody
preventing any kind of tactics on the D
file with the rook on d8 hitting the
bishop on d6 I like to move f6 get not
only does it guard g7 but also cements
the e5 square as a potential use for one
of those tonight that could be annoying
though is that as soon as King f7
happens there's always this move f4
uh-huh that really disturbs the
coordination of the bishop on e6 and the
g6 and there's also this nasty move
Bishop to c4 that happens as soon as you
play King f7 in the future and that
diagonal is something that black can't
contests so I think f4 f5 can find with
Bishop c4 might even be I didn't mean
decisive yeah he's gonna he's might have
to sacrifice yeah and I think he I think
he does write the as you said the threat
of f5 everybody the for coming to the
knight and Bishop was so much that
really there was probably no way to deal
with that other than what you're seeing
now but if if Maxime cakes with the
Queen Amman is is Geoffrey gonna go play
Queen takes e4 that maybe he goes and
gets another pawn back it looks like
he's at least feigning that that might
be possible but that looks almost insane
to me isn't yellow f5 is very close to
working it's just Bishop f3 and rook e1
so yeah a common play hard to believe
that black is gonna be surviving this
and maxime now kind of taking his time
eating some snacks here as you can see
you've got he's got his three mer gamer
gamer headphones going and probably
listening to some music will make sure
we ask him about that and but I agree
with you it looks like Queen takes e5
just seems like White has a lot of
options to be better and certainly black
maybe he has to but black doesn't really
want to trade and go to the endgame
where white just has the dominant bishop
pair and and still threats of f5 in the
air so right although I would have to
say that if I could get the Queen's off
at any rate here as black that would
almost feel like like a win a small
victory race victory but yeah I think
Maxine is looking to keep the tension in
the position alive now I mean he he
leaves the knight on c5 and now there's
three pieces for black that are hanging
so he he's planning to play ninety five
if you take on e6 if you take with the
night there's Queen takes e5 so after
pin to the King in after F takes e6 are
we gonna see King cakes I think we are
there's Bishop but anymore check and
then I had to be a maid basically or at
least a lot of material lost I think
maybe did you just kind of forget the F
file was was opened after this because
this this doesn't look good at all right
well blunders happen when
in a bad position so it looks likely
that Jeffrey did just forget showing
this line again that at the end of the
line the F pawn is pinned and with only
20 seconds probably a resignation as in
is in his near future if you're Jeffrey
but maybe you get a little bit of nerves
out of the way or maybe you just get
reminded that as much as you like the
knight or if you are coming up against
perhaps the greatest Knight or player in
this generation right and so a bit of a
a bit of a what is it a reality check
there for Jeffrey and and we'll see how
he plays in the next the next time he
faces he for whether he chooses to go
for the night over again so all right
well we we have a decisive game in the
books here am on it is now we have a and
then we get the night over but right
back right back in your face Jeffrey
says you know what let me let me show
you how it's done right but here he
plates the Queen takes deep for line
right that's a line you play right I
played I played this before I like to
play the sidelines you know not the
regular Maxime would would have a field
day with me and any type of regular
night or so against the the top guys I
mean you can imagine with Jeffrey in
preparation for this match he must be
looking at the the night or flight
almost exclusively and he's probably
chosen a few sidelines that he feels are
comfortable just regular positions to
play where he probably fares better than
trying to take on Maxine in some some
really theory well it'll be interesting
we'll ask them after the match right did
Jeffrey do some preparation was he
prepared to kind of test max seems night
off and then and then switch it up
obviously we'll find out the next time
that Jeffrey's black but now going into
the night off his white I think probably
only Fabiano Caruana goes regularly into
mem BLS night orphe
when he's white you don't see many other
people challenge Maxime because why a
lot of people would like to see Maxime
in an in a World Championship style
match right against someone like Carlson
and we wouldn't get a lot of e fives I
think he would be curious to see what
happens when you have dynamic opening
like that challenging somebody and a lot
of people just try to avoid Maxime
Sicilian because he's fearless he he
plays it against anyone and to his
credit fabbi is also quite fearless he
he goes right into it where everyone
chooses a calm sideline right but would
you say it's a little worrying for
Jeffrey that you know first game of the
match you you try
this Benoni thing it's just immediately
your your kind of repeating as white in
the first game for draw I don't know if
he's gonna play it again really after
that and then in the second game you
play the knight Worf yeah against the
knight or guide and he comes up with
this crazy novelty that you basically
can't play the line that you just played
because there's not enough time between
games to remedy such a crazy move like
the Knight takes e5 that sacrifice that
we saw and Geoffrey's a young player so
who know maybe he'll go for that Knight
over again and kind of say hey I want to
see that novelty one more time and
actually learn from this cuz that might
be something that improves his over the
board chess so one of the things here
about the Queen being on D for everybody
is the D file is more aggressively
opened in this line so there's all kinds
of tactics in the center whether White's
trying for a five and some positions
Bishop takes f6 sort of overwhelming the
bishops responsibilities here to guard
everything so this line is is sort of
based on white getting this kind of
rapid development and pressure on the D
file but as black plays Knight c6 here
at some point gains a temple on the
Queen you're still going to get a pretty
traditional dynamic Sicilian where
White's either attacking on the Kings
side or in the center and and black is
trying to use the Queen side to get
counter play this Bishop b5 check and
Bishop d7 this is a slightly unorthodox
way that this line happens right you
play this line but normally we would see
the black knight on c6 already so what
do you think Maxime is thinking about
here well one thing about this line
danny's is actually really common for
the position to have two bishops against
two knights okay white often has the
idea to play Bishop takes on f6 often
bit earlier than this and black
sometimes has to take G takes to get out
that hanging deep on yep and when the
night goes to c6
most of the time white plays Bishop to
b5 to keep that nice Queen on d4 and
then plays Bishop takes c6 you know
sometimes you can get these positions
with complete and balanced and that's
those are what people like to play
because those are just chess positions
not much theory to guide you from there
but as we see here at Bishop b5 was
played Bishop d7 so the knight is still
coming to c6
I think Maxime is planning to even
sacrifice a pawn in a lot of these
positions like Bishop takes f6 maybe
Bishop takes f6 is and give us a voice
planning
yeah maybe bring that Queen 85 or
something just yeah over on our analysis
board I was showing the line of mom was
talking about us normally
like he said and natural developing
moves normally lead to a position like
this where White's giving up both
bishops here and and to make sure they
keep that Queen in the center of the
pressure but because this line this this
game took on a strange move order where
the bishops were actually traded for
each other
White is now one the pawn on d6 but I
think blacks probably looking to play
Queen a5 here in a lot of positions to
to get some counter play to justify that
pawn sack yeah I think I'm wondering if
the move that he's bothered by is
something to do with E 5 and some type
of aggressive reply to Queen I five
because I think that if white you know
reacts to Queen a5 with something absurd
like Knight a three or something to
defend the a to pawn in the b5 Knight if
he plays reactive I think black is
extremely happy with sacrificing that
pond but okay if white doesn't trade the
Queen's here then I would be very very
surprised so white does trade the
Queen's and and really with that healthy
pawn I mean Black has some compensation
for sure in the Sicilian you have the
bishop on the diagonal you're gonna have
the C file in this minority attack but I
I don't think it would be unfair to say
that Jeffry won the opening battle this
time I mean he's up a pollen and we
headed to an end game now this is the
like I don't even think this is close to
counter play we might see Maxine must or
something up because he's Maxine but not
because the position is actually okay
for black right that pawn on C 3 blunts
the bishop it blunts the C file that is
like the cleanest extra pawn you'll
you'll ever see
and I think that Maxine was more
concerned that if he went for that Queen
a5 there might have been some very
active reply like 'if I've in the center
so I'm not sure what it was but he saw
something that maybe no one else saw
that that kind of made him trade the
Queen's there and now he's just clearly
down upon and we'll probably just see
rook d1 and he's gonna have to go for
that endgame so night against Bishop
with an extra pawn Danny and a time
advantage for Geoffrey so kind of the
first time we've seen that of the to
start the match so definitely one where
the young American is in control of this
game if he can convert this full point
up only a pullin it's gonna take some
some good old school Russian technique
to really win this one should I say
Canadian technique or Russian technique
is still acceptable
sure the Canadians really really shine
in the end games I'm not sure where we
shine but but you feel like you'd be
showing somewhere you know we must shine
somewhere but I'm not sure it would be
the end game so how do you win an
endgame like this when you have an extra
pawn already you would say from a
classical standpoint letting your pawns
be fixed on dark squares as white is
maybe less than ideal because it gives
that bishop
some sort of long-term goal to undermine
those pawns but okay when an extra pawn
probably blacks blacks chances of
getting and working the bishop around
there aren't very high they're not very
high but it increases the chance of
something like ef ef and then black can
play the move H for HUF eh - fun hanging
or the move f4 and if you place both of
those moves maybe just every pawn on the
Kings side gets liquidated which is
completely in Black's favor
yes trying to trade trade trade and
eventually one pawn advantage if it's
just a single pawn Black's gonna
sacrifice his bishop and make it Ross so
I feel like King e6 here in black has
achieved a lot more than white in this
endgame I would have thrown the move h3
in when the pawns were on h5 and g5 just
to not let that pawn get fixed there
like that and if he plays g4 maybe h4
and fix the H pawn I own h5 is a
weakness because in this position maybe
his Knight f4 check just just
potentially winning oh well now if a
white late night of four and forced the
key right one inning I wonder if Mex he
missed that okay but he didn't play okay
he couldn't play Knight f4 check I'll
move before right because the king of it
isn't it isn't it coming by force here
just Knight f4 so if H well King e5
Knight f4 and if h4 I have an IG 6 yeah
and why you know white is gobbling up
the pollen and two pawns are better than
one so Maxime has something to figure
out here and that's probably why he's
thinking it almost has to play like king
d6 or like yeah Bishop e6 I'm not sure
that this looks like
Jeffrey's night on g2 is fianchettoed
night here is very very crafty because
Knight f4 that's a terrible pawn
structure yeah and he does go for king
g6 dr. Knight f4 he does want to play
the beach for right and that wouldn't be
possible after king e5 right but he
gives up King space here and one at one
idea for white is is there
I'm always looking at ways to maybe run
the king forward perhaps you just
advance on the queenside first no he's
going for this line we're gonna find out
one of the risks when you put all the
pawns on light squares having the bishop
despite will be unfortunately
highlighted about the pawns being stuck
on dark squares is that the bishop can't
really defend them so as this knight
came into f4 and hit the h5 pawn there
was no choice but to make a sacrifice so
I think if the pawns were even then what
Maxine did would would make a lot more
sense but because he's down upon why you
can put him in this awkward position
where he's offering this terrible pawn
structure with Knight f4 Knight f4
potentially check and he just can't take
because there's a path bomb coming right
queen side well he still has a
strategical drawing some drawing chances
here I mean he can bring the king to g6
and h5 and White has some things to
figure out in regards to defending the H
pawn and the Queen side hasn't gotten
rolling yet this is where White's extra
pawn is but if black black played King
g6 and King takes h4 here he's getting
some pretty good counter play on the
Kings side how was white dealing with
King to g6 yeah the thing that I like is
that of King g6 I want to play King to
e4 potentially and if any you can go
back to g3 right I'm not sure how how
well that works cuz maybe 90 to g3 there
could be Bishop e6 trying to take on f2
and I think that's sort of what Maxime
is thinking that if he leaves a bishop
on b6 and then also leaves a king on g6
he's got these two threats of the f2
pond and then king g6 King h5 and if
King e4 I don't think you're in time to
grab the Jeep on I'm playing bishop f2
and Bishop takes g-iii and f2 so yeah
luckily defend it if you go for that
line with Bishop takes g3 the king can
take and then the black king may end up
overworked in regards to defending the H
pass pawn and the Queen side majority
but yeah that line with Bishop takes f2
I don't even know that taking g3 is 4 so
you might be able to play Bishop c1 and
go after the h2 pawn right well here
white is actually not even in time to
take the Jeep on so King efore Bishop f2
king f4 maybe bishops you want like you
said and
I'm sure if if Jeffrey is even playing
for the win there it has to be careful
so yeah he's backtracking yeah he
doesn't like it and I won't trap
everybody be aware now that the King has
not filled the e4 square the obvious
fork after Bishop takes f2 as it's 94
checks so Jeffrey setting a little bit
of a trap there to make sure that he can
defend the f2 pawn Maxime doesn't
blunder and now he's just gonna bring
the King all the way back but but yeah
it's weird to see white up to pawns here
yet completely on the defensive - Mac
seems more active King and this really
sort of tricky Bishop on the dark
squares yeah he he has cemented this F
to fajn it's like a dark square weakness
he's got the dark square bishop I still
feel that white can even do something
like bring his King to g1 and consider
the move h3 to break he's got a pass on
on the Queen side he just has to make it
and then he's got this H bond so he's
got the to pass pawns
the potential for to passed pawns here
and I just think he has to get those
bonds going and try this h3 plan
together that feels like it should be
should be enough but it's hard though to
mobilize the Queen side pawns if okay
now he sacrificed the H pawn in order to
go get this fork that's I think that's
the right idea for sure and I wonder if
maxime just didn't see that you can
actually see going king h4 and he's got
to go for counter play right maybe b6
and then King h4 maybe just king h4 King
h-street try to take that pawn but the
nice thing is white plays King f1 and
just just completely sits there and
pushes the Queen side because King's on
the light square on f1 g3 you just take
it it's it's actually just kind of home
free for white here ya know it looks
like the moment that that was executed
with the night coming d4 and c5 it
looked like
maxime had maybe missed this this sort
of chance for a white to get out of that
bind and this could be huge I mean if
the underdog strikes here and gets his
first point he levels the match score
and proves this isn't gonna be a runaway
train there write something so does that
happen in that opening I doubt we'll see
Maxime repeat that line again and yeah
Maxime just throws in the towel and says
nope well-played youngster let's do this
thing again yeah that worked a lot
better for Geoffrey that game I think
you'll be happy with going for the
sidelines and
and sort of not getting Maxime out of
book because can you really ever get
Maxime out of book right but he did kind
of get him in a position that maybe he
had prepared or at least he was
comfortable with it seemed like Jeffrey
was playing that one a lot more
confidently in the first two games and
here we have our first Berlin so you
lost the bet Aman it didn't take a half
an hour before a Berlin was played and I
don't think we'll see a lot of Berlin's
but who knows it's it's something Maxime
has played and been been in he's invited
to Berlin in his speed chess matches we
saw him do it against Nakamura last year
was so Maxime is no stranger to the
white side of the Berlin in these in
these blitz battles that we've had so a
lot about what about his game against
the car yakin in st. Louis what about
that ridiculous like I don't know was it
40 moves of theory and basically the
whole game was theory and Kuryakin was
down like two hours just making sure he
remembered it
I mean Maxime has as some of the
nastiest preparation it's using in the
Berlin
well he's willing to test it and if you
remember that that match whiz Nakamura
he it was they I don't know how many
games but it was at least four or five
games where they were both sort of
pushing each other theoretically I mean
we were getting we were getting to move
30 and both sides had more than five
minutes on the clock so so yeah I mean
they you know Maxime is a Berlin
specialist along with the night off and
we'll see if he if he gets rolling in
this one too you wondered sometimes when
they're thinking if he's trying to
remember preparation or at this point he
just understands the positions well
enough to know that here he wants to
bring this night over to the affor
Square to eliminate that Bishop on g6
this looks like an awkward line for
black guy and again I'm not a Berlin
expert but I I can't help but like
White's idea here or bringing the Knight
to f4 and I think if g6 is eliminated
white is happy so we'll see how it deals
with this right black always has the
possibility like for example here if he
trades the the Knights it doesn't look
that good to have that pawn on e6 but
again as long as he doesn't like if he
trades dark square bishop for Knight
he's gonna have a slightly worse
position but at the end of the day those
are opposite color bishops and he has
all his chances to make
draw so I actually think that in terms
of the match situation I would much
rather be playing like a Berlin end game
and just trying to grapple with Maxine
than yelling into some of his main line
openings because everybody knows that
the evaluation the objective evaluation
is really equality or at least a draw
and eventualities so you know you have
to work really hard to prove that
against Maxine but at the end of the day
I'd rather be playing this and then some
of this you know like the the wind that
we saw earlier in the night or FM yeah
I'd rather this position absolutely
that's one of the advantages of the
Berlin is no matter how deep the theory
guess you're basically playing an
unbalanced ending where black is a
little positionally worse with the
doubled pawns and and white has the the
four on three majority but black has the
bishop pair and and right now he's
probably considering whether he wants to
go grab that c2 pawn with his bishop
pair and make a trade
I'm gonna guess he doesn't and plays b6
but and with the kind of a traditional
Berlin idea where the King runs itself
off the D file and and then black
eventually brings the rook to d8 to
challenge the only open file but I know
Geoffrey thinking about okay
he does decide not to take it and starts
that plan not with b6 but similar gonna
bring the King to c6 I think that Bishop
c2 was probably okay there but everyone
has this this fear and rightfully so of
rooks e1 Bishop moves in that Bishop c5
and white if he could trade anything he
would like to trade dark squared Bishop
sand rise try to melt some advantage of
night against Bishop so he's not gonna
allow this him keep the bishop there and
I think that if he can recycle that
Bishop from g60 d6 that feels like it
would be a kind of more compact because
I'm I'm wondering if there's some e six
minutes here for white not not always
but it is a common theme yeah so after
this check I was just thinking the same
thing depending on where this King goes
is why it takes f4 c4 I think CSIS c4
makes sense usually but here you can't
do it cuz the e5 pawn is hanging I think
do you do it and play root da yeah I was
just gonna say I think it's hanging but
maybe at the end of this line is not
because of the the pin they're causing
some dysfunction to Black's development
yeah because the thing is if y
losses that ePHI pon it's also not the
end of the world because it's basically
just kind of like the right on three in
eventualities so right maybe c4 is kind
of a tricky version here and then you
don't even need to waste time with that
for you just like rook d5 and then rook
d1 next yep but white white just has F
or g3 see for coming it looks like he's
decided Bishop f4 and I think he's he's
really pushing for this East six idea
I'm not sure I like it because I think
what he's saying is okay if you develop
there should be seven i I have e6 coming
and certainly black doesn't want some
sort of trade of the structure here
that'd be terrible but black and black
would like to play rook e6 that would be
a natural way to stop East six but here
comes your rook d8 idea again right so I
think I think Bishop before looking at
it now on the board seems really strong
right you're you're asking black some
tough questions are you gonna stop e6
and allow rook d8 or how else are you
completing your development on the Kings
side perhaps we see yeah I feel like
rook h5 here now the thing about rook h5
is it's it's definitely very artificial
and if you just sit there with you know
your your bishop maybe back to Chi 3
maybe even the move chief or yeah
Moochie 4 here it just kind of makes the
rook look awkward that's actually what
we're seeing on the board there so
Geoffrey decides Merck h5 but after
after rook age 4 here likely Maxine
would play the simple f3 guard g4 and
that rook on h4 is uh well it's just a
sitting duck for some sort of tactic
wherever the bishop hits it or the King
comes forward so so I agree with you it
again
I was thinking c4 4 black it's not
typical but maybe to put that Bishop on
c5 and play b5 and kind of support
things it's definitely not how you
normally develop in in this opening but
I much prefer it to Brooke h5 where she
foreign Kings you two are clearly
massive massive Tempe for right for
white to just get for free yeah and they
are massive important Tempe everybody
because the kind of the ongoing theme of
the Berlin is White has this four on
three pawn majority and ultimately if
white wins these end games is because
White has found a way to sort of safely
expand on the Kings side and push these
pawns forward so so I agree with you
hindsight is looking like rook h5 maybe
not as good is that that idea you
mentioned perhaps c4 was interesting
you're always worried
I see forth your King on c6 because
there may have been moves like rookie
four and the pawns are coming under fire
so the truth is I mean it seems like
what we prophesized in the beginning
it's you know it's another opening that
Maxine has prepared as deeply as many of
the best players in the world and
Geoffrey has some things to figure out
you can see it on the clock these guys
don't like time pressure everybody this
isn't your chess coach telling you to
take your time and play good moves if
they're taking time it's because they
don't know exactly what to do ya know
he's done the move c-4 at last here
Danny I think he realized that whether
or not he agrees with with me it's
almost a necessity like that bishop gelt
moved to e7 yeah like you said e six is
so strong right as you talked about the
rook can't move because of rook d8 and
now that he's rejected or at least
Maxine has refuted his own rotation five
idea he's he's almost insuk's long yeah
if you're in the middle game or I guess
we're quite close to an Indian but see
for his required heat he has to play
Bishop c5 next and a4 is played exactly
what the idea we've been talking about I
think it just makes rookie forward that
much stronger if working for immediately
I think it's pretty clear that black
would have played b5 to defend the C
pawn so Maxime taking his time plays a4
pokes fun at the be 5 square and I think
that c4 pawn will regret its advance and
you know it's just another looks like
another very very clean technical very
well prepared Berlin and and it's hard
not to like white with where this game
is headed yeah and another thing is that
white might even consider in some cases
playing the move
b3 I would prefer to treat that pawn on
c4 as a weakness but yeah he does go for
b3 now and yeah the idea is that the c5
square is not as comfy so to speak when
when you play C takes b3 and then
there's a rook c1 trickin in most
positions so he's decided Geoffrey to
give it up yeah it's a nice idea I think
I mean it even though again I think
white is in the driver's seat doesn't
change our evaluation I think from a
practical perspective emphasizing the
development of that Bishop was much more
important than black saving that c4 pawn
for sure and so now Maxime has to decide
do I take and double my C pawns a pawn
is a pawn or do I play brookie for
anyway and try to force the issue kind
of force black to take on b3
right yeah rookie 4 does force that to
be taken because the issue is not that
white doesn't want to take on c4 it's
that he doesn't wanna spawns to be
doubled so after rookie 4 B 5
well then I'm more than happy to take
and then take wow look at this so it max
team decides to do it well he must be he
must be highlighting that he likes the
d5 square Ahmad right you mentioned that
idea earlier it is a key point in the
Berlin that the d5 square is at some
point used for either a rook lift like
this to double on the D file sometimes a
knight so he decides he's willing to
double the pawns cuz he's gonna get that
d5 square for the rook and I kind of
think that's his that's his point and
here he goes yeah I think g5 is
extremely important young puts the pawn
on the dark square but f4 and f5 like
that that just can't be allowed yeah in
that position so his rook wants to stay
on e6 the pollens gonna stay on g5 and
at least from a practical perspective I
really like what Geoffrey has has done
the last couple moves but he wants to
buzz bishop may be back on b6 probably
it's not gonna work too hard to keep the
c4 pawn here and maybe Bishop d6 and
King to b7 and and bring the rook to t8
but well we'll see okay so he's working
harder than I thought that he wants that
c4 pot yeah he plays Bishop before of
course the risk is I mean at this point
you're not even really threatening
anything because the bishop is pinned to
the king yeah and if the rook moves and
immediately black has to worry about
ideas like c3 that said it's you know
the king is active in the center that's
that's a key and game principle and if
there's no threat of c3 black might
place c5 here I'm on support the bishop
get that one out of a rook f3 yeah Rick
f3 with f7 hanging and also c3 um that
that looks kind of kind of bad I'm
curious why he didn't go for that
although okay he played rook a3 and then
the c3 pawn his sacrifice he okay maybe
he wanted a free pawn first in it yeah
yes that's all he wanted go gobble the
gobble the C pawn first I still think
black plays King C for just gonna say
and then plays Bishop takes e5 tries to
tries his best to hold the rook ending
draw but seems like seems like white
will be in the driver's seat in this
rook end
and maybe now he's debating do I even
want to take e5 maybe not maybe Brooke
f5 here if you're Maxime well rookie one
looks ready one pins the bishop
that kind of looks tempting and then
maybe liquidate that way
there's also rook - yeah okay probably
just just capture at this point - I
think I think f5 is also a oh and rookie
for even and and the idea look at this
thread I'm on if King c3 he's gonna play
rook f3 check and then rook III double
the rooks on the e-file winning the
bishop yeah that's very nice so this is
this which I'm not sure is necessarily
an achievement I actually like the
bishop on d4 covering the c5 covering g7
like when when you're in a worse
position let's say it's black you you
kind of say alright what what are the
things that I can't give up or I lose
well if I lose the Jeep on clearly those
three pawns roll and if I lose my seat
on I have no counter play here he's kind
of maintained the only two things in the
position which keep him alive and I have
to say Jeffrey's not can't be that
unhappy with this this looks really
scary to play for white yep down to 15
seconds we may be in store for our first
true time scramble of the match come on
as it looks I mean it's close to equal
here or at least equal chances with both
sides getting under time pressure so now
with White's King having to be on the
first - yeah I mean it's looking like
Geoffrey got a lot more counter play
than we expected out of that position no
no this this is absolutely good for for
black here as you can see he's nearly
mating himself and the C pawn is still
just as dangerous the pawns are all
falling I think Maxime completely missed
evaluated how strong Bishop on d4 would
be because that holds absolutely
everything and now black I mean it's
it's completely his game to win kingi
for and he just wants to keep cleaning
up the pawns the bishop on d4 dominates
the bishop on g3 yep to remind everybody
what that position was where the game
may have just gone on a miscue for
Maxime it was this rookie for Shaq
played by him as you can see in the
analysis board we highlighted that there
was this idea of checking and then
doubling but Maxime clearly missed
Bishop D for saving the day and and I
really it looks like that's where the
position may have gone off the rails for
Maxime and Wow is he
if you take on g7 you can take take and
there's rook a one check at the end
followed by c2
yep but other other than that Bishop f8
is is a useless move if you can't take
on g7 so I think this is just this pawn
is just cleaning here it maxime down on
time and running out of tricks and
resources here I think Bishop comes to
g5 yet there it is and yeah ok you see
still holding for the moment nope he's
not you just mean that he wants to Queen
the pawn and take it and take on g7 I
think that's his last trick and Geoffrey
was a little bit one time there Wow he
he just transitioned to the king of pawn
ending which okay it may be winning but
that was a do you play g5 here I might
be allowing calculate I think he can
play g5 now no he can't if the draw is
in store Wow yeah that's that's I think
a little full French magic there at the
end that was a that was a slippery a
slippery escape there by the Frenchman
yeah I mean well did you see his his
camera Maxime let out a big of yeah a
big smile and a big friend yeah
Geoffrey hasn't really moved all match
so kind of kind of comfortable in his
position got the got the thinking man
statue position going here with with
head in hand and Mac seems all over the
place shoving snacks in his face any
chance he gets but but overall okay
Maxime escapes in that game but given
that you were pushing as black you
defended a worse position of the Berlin
you still got to be feeling pretty good
if you're Geoffrey at this point of the
match yeah I agree I think you you kind
of put the the e4 e5 under your belt is
one to repeat and maybe the knight or FS
one to stay away from for the moment if
you're Geoffrey but the last two games
compared to the first two games
extremely encouraging for for Geoffrey
from his perspective so I think he'll be
happy to repeat some of these lines and
say that it's up to Maxime to to improve
now that being said Maxine was pretty
much pushing I think for most of that
game and I think he lost the thread a
little bit yeah but nevertheless that's
what I was saying I really like the idea
of just playing Maxime in Berlin versus
a
your theoretical line yeah this is a
this is one of those really tricky
positions where a totally symmetrical
but there's a lot more tactics than
first meet the eye here obviously we see
potential trades coming on e4 there's
some critical decisions to be made here
as far as white also having to deal with
the threat of f6 now forking the knight
on e5 and the bishop on g5 what do we
think about this position here well
sometimes the threat of f6 can be met
tactically with with something like a
queen to to b3 right in in some lines
either take on e4 first or bring the
Queen to b3 the e7 pawn is also a little
tender like if white had an extra move
to spare he might have thrown in Queen
a3 which can sometimes be a really
annoying move to face as as black but at
black up just plays 94u wants to trade
the only thing is that knight on b8 is
kind of being played against at the
moment it can't move the a6 square is
taken and obviously c6 and d7 are also
kind of off-the-books but f6 is the big
threat that Maxime is making and it's
what White has to react to here but I
think Geoffrey should be happy with this
position saves the bishop and we'll just
see rook d1 rook c1 pretty standard
stuff black does not want to give up the
bishop on g7 for the knight on e5 so
here black can take on c3 and create
this potentially weak pawn on the C file
but really it's something white likes
because then that pawn is coming to the
c-4 square which allows white to
increase the pressure on this long
diagonal so right I think that black has
some has some work cut out here I mean
you highlighted that the knight on b8
can't get in the game so how does he
deal with that certainly he'd like to
play a move like f6 to kick the knight
but you already highlighted it that at
some point if that happens you may see
you may see diagonal problems maybe not
exactly with it with an immediate trade
on e4 and check as a bishop d5 by black
but but but you can take on e4 with the
bishop potentially and try to win some
some material that way and there's also
Queen b3 in general a bishop takes e4
f'd a c5 Queen b3 and maybe some pawns
are hanging in this
I'm not sure b5 is an option by black he
actually goes for it at that that seems
right maybe he'll even play e6 now even
though maybe not your favorite move
positionally you gotta guard the d5 pawn
in order to get this knight on b8
developed right well a4 is coming Danny
and that's that's the tough thing that
you can't play knight c6 or Knight d7
alright I'm sorry maybe you could I
think I was gonna say I think he will
because he wants to sack the pawn and
then play Knight takes e5 and get it
back that way because if he didn't do
that he went slow with east 6 I think a
4 was just gonna be a huge problem in
this side yeah yeah so he justifies
developing with tactics since the d5
pawn is hanging but at the end of a line
like this everybody Bishop takes d5
Bishop takes Queen takes black plays
Knight takes e5 and just gonna be a big
fancy way to make trades and then black
is probably actually very happy in an
endgame like that with the c3 pawn being
the biggest weakness on the board after
the smoke clears so so now Geoffrey has
some things to think about he's got
options here
he's got f4 as an option he's got 93 is
an option yeah he's got a 4 is an option
the same idea that you mentioned before
is maybe the best thing because if black
takes on e5 and just wins the pawn on e5
which looks like Maxime is going for
that could play Bishop c6 but I agree I
think he's just gonna sort of liquidate
my to liquidate everything
I don't think white takes on b5 and
let's see 3 hang I think white tries to
switch and gang up on the D pawn first
oh I'm wrong ok he takes and he's just
trading everything though so probably we
are I think there's potential for white
to to attempt to claim a slight
advantage with maybe and move like
Bishop d4 next and just say that the
bishop on g2 is better than the bishop
on B side wait so you're saying I move
like Queen c8 to guard the bishop put
the bishop on d4 oh wow well we're gonna
get a sacrifice here Maxime takes on c3
potentially giving up the bishop on b7
what's what's he calculating here this
this looks like two bishops are hanging
well the Brooklyn II one was was hanging
and then if Brooke a8 he wanted to take
bishop takes a and get out of trouble
right but afterwards c1 now we've got
problems to figure out yes I think I
I'm assuming that he was calculating
some some stuff with Bishop a6 but now
there's Bishop a6 Queen d5 in in the
position to think about it the c3 Bishop
is just hanging this entire time and the
a rook is is hanging as well so I'm not
sure if Maxie saw the way through all
that but it's the kind of position where
like I was saying if black played
passively with queen c8 maybe maxine
didn't like the idea of a bishop to d4
and just that annoying pressure of being
slightly worse so he tries to solve his
problems tactically and I'm not sure how
this ends up working here this this is
either gonna be just a dead draw or it's
gonna be very dicey for black yeah that
rook c8 move was a shocker he had to get
up after that one somehow Maxime got out
of that whole mess without losing any
pieces so Dani when you got to go to the
washroom you gotta go yeah you gotta go
you got to go right and after work c8
maybe he felt like well no better time
than now he was up almost a minute on
the clock and so he he had that going
for him he's not even down on time at
this point and he's been gone for 30
seconds so and did maxy maxy my offer to
draw right that's that's what's on the
board as far as I can see so is he gonna
come back and just click accept that is
right there that's online gamesmanship
you know that's that's him recognizing
that used used the practical situation
to his advantage get a bathroom break in
when you have a control guaranteed and
we have a tied match two and a half two
and a half and I think Jeffrey is okay
to repeat for now and this is not very
common at all to play Queen e2 Danny and
in the Berlin and now this is gonna test
what I would I would say I don't
actually play the Berlin that much
myself but I'm willing to say this has
got to be slightly offbeat you don't
usually see the Queen's on in the middle
game yeah
the this is gonna be not not the typical
not the typical Berlin here
because if the Queens aren't traded that
means that black has some things to
figure out with the king in the center
here comes the night trying to undermine
the protection of the of the other night
on e4 but Jeffrey played Queen CA pretty
quickly so maybe he knows what he's
doing in this line is he just developing
naturally here Bishop e7 or Bishop c5
tried to get the King castled and and
then played the middle game right I
think Bishop e7 95-96 and maybe give the
knight sorry give the bishop for the
night and try to play that position
that's what he's done I don't think he
can be too upset in fact but the knight
on e6 Queen sits on that five and just
trying to bring the rooks to the D file
and once again we have the typical four
against three but this one is looking a
lot better than than last time I have to
say yeah I like blacks position here too
I mean I guess just my instincts say
you're not at least gonna get grinded
out in the Berlin endgame the Maxime
knows theoretically very well Maxime
tries to trick him with this side line
but now he's gone into the think tank so
as far as time goes it suggests that
Maxime is either trying to remember
theory or doesn't really think he got
very much out of the opening well Danny
Queen e2 is not not a pop variation I
mean the the best move is for sure to
take the Queen on d8 so it could be one
of the cases where he's playing this
line because he thinks his opponent
might not be prepared for it or he's
testing his knowledge and Geoffrey is
saying well look I'm up a minute I know
what I'm doing here this is just equal
or maybe blacks already comfortable
already and Maxime is wondering you know
how can he spice things up here or at
least try to trick Geoffrey but the more
pieces that get traded the easier it is
for black to play and I think this is
just a case of a line that's not top
Theory getting played properly by black
right yeah and you thought that might be
the case when he played Queen to c8 and
now it's the case that Maxime is
thinking a lot so let's take a moment
remind everybody the thousands of you on
Twitch thanks for being here speech has
championship game on what's at stake
let's just remind everybody real quick
of course there is a lot going on we've
already had the best players so many of
the best players in the world play and
win their matches moving on to the
second round the winner of this match
will take on Sasha crook
and I've just also been informed that we
have we have a contest going on on
social media if you use the hashtag
speech s Photoshop contest like for
Reddit right anybody who can Photoshop a
beard on to me that looks half as manly
as a Mont Hamilton's I'm on fluff out
that beard for us show the fans what
that looks like
anybody can Photoshop a beard onto me
that looks half as manly and natural you
get a one-year Diamond membership on
chest comm so if you've been coveting
that premium membership now's your
chance
use the hashtag speech s and in
Photoshop a beard on to me one that I
will never actually be able to grow and
we'll check in with that at some point
later on in the show but okay
things are getting spicy now we just
said it was gonna be a middle game where
blacks seem comfortable but here comes
here comes Lyon beast aggressively
expanding his Kings side and we might be
in store for a sharper game that we
thought yeah this g4 is quite committal
for sure but I I secretly expected
something like this from Maxine not that
I think he has prepared this because the
time sort of indicates he hasn't but it
looks as though he's maybe slightly
frustrated or just kind of saying that
he hasn't got anything from the open yo
and he wants to make a point that that
it's not just gonna be an easy draw or
something so he's always kind of yeah
he's all in he's all in and normally the
reason why this looks risky for us
everybody is normally you just don't see
this type of aggressive expansion when
it's your own King that's opening up and
in and Geoffrey says all right well then
let's do this thing I play a5 and open
it up right back likely we see the
endgame happen but you have to like you
still have to like where this went for
black there's threats of Bishop takes c3
doubling the pawns the f4 pawn is weak
for white so I still feel like Geoffrey
is doing just fine in this game yeah
it's the type of position if you if you
give white just a few moves like c3 here
looks like a very important move that
that he wants to play because it blunts
the bishop takes control the d4 square
if white can get like maybe Bishop d2 or
Bishop e3 followed by C 3 he's he's
likely just just nearly winning but
obviously black is is playing on the
fact that he's got these 10 beats fair
but yeah I think you have to play
accurately because if white gets
something like maybe pawn now 5c3 that
Bishop comes to f4 this this could be a
clear advantage for for white if blacks
not careful
yeah f5 would be key so Geoffrey is
thinking about that he would have loved
to have played Bishop d4 check everybody
and then gobbled a4 but as a mom pointed
out once that bishops on d4 the night is
the night is serving a duty there to
protect the bishop so so that means he
has some things to figure out how's he
gonna maybe does the up g6 to deal with
f5 at least in that case if f5 is played
you can capture it and then play against
this weakness for the rest of the game
how else is he gonna deal with the
threat of a five if not g6 yeah I'm I'm
not sure either he's gonna just permit
f5 and try to play let's say woah
tactics going to something he's got
Bishop takes b2 coming if Bishop takes
up for Bishop takes b2 and at the end of
the slide everybody is it's actually a
really good trade for black if
everything went to plan so sure no I was
talking about the line that if he played
rook b1 and gave it four but I agree
with you now we've got the knight in
Bishop versus the Brooke and that was
kind of the risk there you've got to of
rook versus two miners normally we favor
the miners but this is also a pretty
open position and black does have the
extra pawn yeah so yeah hard to say the
black is really that much worse in this
endgame here even though normally we
really like the miners no the problem is
the coordination if that pawn on c2 was
on b2
right and imagine a bishop sitting on c3
protecting everything there there's some
coordination to have there but here
there's there's no nice piece
coordination that I pricey so it
requires White's that probably make some
sacrifices like here one of those funds
is falling and you know I was looking at
the video when Jeffery played takes on
f4 and maxeen kind of kind of gave that
2800 nod of approval like that right
that's probably the right right thing
but not that I've never been given in
life that's what you're saying yeah yeah
no you're right now after rook d2
everybody I'm on point of why the pawns
are hanging is because now black can
play rook a3 and that rook
can no longer go to a 100 or or a rookie
one check and rook a 1 which looks like
that's gonna be well either rook a 1 or
Brooksie one actually Geoffrey seems to
have his choice of Poland's right to go
after whether it's the c2 or the 81 I
think you want the SI phan if you can
choose yes it means the a pond is in the
bag maybe cuz if you get the C pawn
you're probably forcing a rook straight
and as a kind of an instructive reminder
for everybody if you got the rooks
versus the minors and they are
struggling for coordination if you can
trade off White's rook it's for a lot
easier for your rook to kind of dominate
the board the open files would favor the
rook so Maxime knows that and he's not
gonna let his rook be traded kind of
going all in for some counter play now
and I think the counter play is is very
real here because the King can hide on
h3 and if black ever gets the idea to
double Brooks on the second ring there's
that Bishop on c7 which simply covers
each two so right I'm not that scared as
white leaving my King on h3 play Knight
f5 going for these Queen side pawns and
then the two the pieces start to find
some coordination it comes at the cost
of a few pawns but the the minor pieces
thrive when they can coordinate and the
ropes thrive obviously when they can
just start picking up pawns use that
length of the board but here I think
obviously is going to take that pawn
hide the King on h3 Knight f5 and and
we're gonna see this position develop
well one of the risks is that if the
black king is is caught in the center
and those miners do get coordinators
Amon has been harping on you got mating
net issues but but as long as that rook
stays on the third-ranked here white has
some problems right Amon he can't play
King gauge for cuz h2 hangs but if you
can't play king h4 how's he gonna unpin
the knight and Geoffrey I think
recognizes that it's kind of optimal
starts pushing alright but here we go we
got a race I like white I think that the
Jeep on combined with the two pieces and
the rook is a serious threat now he he
brings the rook
kind of crafty that there's no Knight f5
now but this this could get this could
get pretty dicey here yeah I'm looking
at around g6
I'm looking at g6 here as a candidate
rook h2 King g4 yep rook age seven takes
root gauge - maybe Knight h5 they're
blocking the rook and forcing the Queen
home I agree and
maxime also likes your line
we'll see what Jeffrey has in store here
likely not gonna play Brooke h7 maybe he
has work a 4 check and then try to bring
the other book back but the truth is the
G pawn just looks like it's just too
poorly so like that Bishop on c7 is just
perfect right guards the night on g3 and
and you know just everybody's coming
together the rook guards the bishop the
bishop guards the knight and that's a
happy family yeah one thing about the
the rook standing is I think that he was
focused at Geoffrey was focusing a
little too much on trying to take all
the pawns and what happened was he's got
three connected passed pawns but they're
all like five six moves away from
queening that that they're not making a
threat white only has one pawn on g6 but
it's it's the hero here I mean it's
going all the way it's a good reminder
when you're calculating these end games
it's not always how many pawns you have
but who Queens first and I think I think
really if we go back to that position
where we first kind of questions
Geoffrey's approach I was originally
suggesting maybe rook a 3 instead of
rook e1 check and after rook e1 check
suddenly it becomes clear that what you
said is true I think that's where he
really kind of underestimated Maxine's
idea of just giving up the C pawn and
going for counter play so hindsight's
2020 but I think back in that moment was
sort of critical and where black maybe
let the thread slip so I I mean Bishop
d8 seems to me to play the movie 7 check
remove the King the other way and then
play g7 I actually thought when the
bishop was on c7 that he was gonna play
g7 king f7 and then maybe Bishop e5 and
then just rotate and try to promote the
pawn that way he might have been worried
about ideas like rook a3 and sacks on g3
and just takes on g7 or something
sacking everything to stop the Jeep on
yeah yeah no Maxine once like he wants
to clean he doesn't want to Brooke and
Bishop against rook and any
eventualities he's looking to Queen this
Jeep on right after it came to d6 I'm
gonna guess we're gonna get some sort of
endgame where maybe black gifs check on
a4 takes the bishop and after white gets
a queen tries to take the rook on e7 and
hope the Queen and Knight don't mate but
I'm gonna guess that Batman and Robin
get the job done there so I think the
Queen and Knight will just create some
sort of mating net but I don't see any
other option here I mean I think after a
king to d6 g7 I think you have to
for some light like rook a four check
and yeah there's rook a four but I mean
the pawn is simply Queenie you can even
play rookie four in that decision yeah I
haven't seen anything for four black
here well Geoffrey might just take it
Geoffrey is down on the clock as well
and not a lot of time to decide how he
wants to swindle here he goes for a line
like that challenging the Queen and
Knight but he better run run run with
the king before the Queen and Knight
made him yeah he's gonna try to try to
get that King over to b6 okay the
position has certainly lost for black
but some some small remaining practical
chances with time but I expect Maxime to
do whatever business take care of
business here bring that Knight into
either d6 and e7 bring the Queen over
and we're gonna have a mating net
against the King for sure ya know at
this point it's just a small matter of
technique and Geoffrey definitely knows
that that he lost but that's a pretty
instructive game because it was you know
I think I was right that MV Ellis was
nodding an approval of this idea to go
for the two rooks against the rope and
gripe and night but it still requires
the the technical part after that that
maybe if Maxine was playing black you
might have handled things a bit
differently yeah because it did look
like black was doing the right thing but
it's so easy to miss evaluate or planned
a position with the two pieces against
the rook incorrectly yep no I agree I
think the initial assessment was
accurate I think we said the minors were
gonna struggle for coordination the
Brooks were active there were pawns but
us one small slip all of a sudden
White's pieces came to life on the Kings
side and black was in trouble and Maxime
is gonna win this game we are going to
be moving on to the final half an hour
of the first five minute portion of the
match and with a one with a one game
lead so still you know the underdog is
certainly Andy and Jeffrey's held his
own he's played well overall
I don't expect anything to change here
at least not in the next half hour we'll
see what happens as the time controls
speed up but the the match is on here we
go our first repeat of the day Amon we
have that same nine horf structure that
we saw before
we'll see we'll see how Jeffrey
approaches it but isn't this the exact
same line that Maxine played as white
this is like isn't he repeating his
opponents opening yeah I was gonna say
we had our first repeat but I forgot the
colors from reverse you're right so
actually and now already we are in
something a little bit different Maxime
Maxime says I'm not gonna let you use my
own novelty against me right shakes his
finger and mixes things up so we are not
gonna get that exact line and Maxime
again showing why he's the knight or
expert because look at the clock he has
more than not even started
Maxime keeps putting Geoffrey in these
positions where it's so tempting to take
a draw against a strong player like
Maxine but yeah it's just not efficient
to use your white pieces like that right
we're going where you throw away draw
after draw this blitz chess and you can
play 94 Knight f6 and it seems like the
best move is Bishop III but I feel
happily take that draw yep yeah the
other the other way this is played if
you don't bring the bishop back to e3 I
mean is there ideas of sometimes playing
b3 and try to relocate the bishop to the
Queen side to hit these six but normally
that backfires because the C file
becomes a problem yeah that's that's
definitely a possibility here he does go
for Bishop III and based on the first
game it seemed like in the benoni that
is Geoffrey was kind of willing to do
this and just sort of you know maybe he
feels he's better in the shorter time
controls and he's just sort of killing
them you're gonna say that it's an
interesting match strategy because while
I agree with you right you don't want to
use your white pieces in this way we saw
the benoni draw we may see another one
here but also if you're the underdog and
you're not happy with what you got
maxime look at the time right I mean
he's already up on almost a minute and a
half so from that perspective maybe
Geoffrey feels like he might be a more
of a challenge for Maxime and bullet
than than some of maxim's previous
matches so right we're gonna see it
alright well see if it pays off see how
Geoffrey does is the time control speed
up yeah we'll definitely have to ask him
about that afterwards because I
personally feel that and I think most
people share this opinion that the white
pieces are way more valuable than black
especially I think that's compounded in
blitz and it's right to the bullet so
I'm not sure how Geoffrey is gonna feel
you know maybe he starts to get that
feeling that he's just defending
slightly worse positions with black
maybe losing them maybe drawing them and
then giving MVL the easy way out with
the white pieces eventually that could
backfire but if he defends with black
then maybe we're all we're all wrong
right no but I agree I think the reason
why we foreshadow it that way is because
that's likely the most the most common
road travel is Jeffrey will not be happy
with what he got out of the white pieces
but the match is young and this is gonna
be fun so we have another Berlin maybe
we will be in in for a Berlin Theory day
a weird weird Berlin with this night
getting itself established on e6 one of
the advantages of that everybody is the
night actually guards some critical
squares like d4 where the night always
wants to come f4 which is a very common
square for the white bishop and even g5
but the disadvantage of the night on e6
Amman is very clear right you block the
bishop on c8 which is sort of a key
point for black kind of completing the
disfunctional Queen side and getting
that King off the D file so interesting
right a unique position for the knight
on e6 that does some good but but maybe
it'll it'll be trouble for the
LightSquared bishop right right no at
this point it's it's the fact that the
knight only six like you said Bloggs the
bishop it's also more vulnerable there
things like f4 f5 right so basically
black is going for the sort of short
term solution where there's no Knight g5
no Bishop f4 no Knight e4 taking squares
but he's got them now the long-term
problem of how does he actually get
developed and sometimes the long-term
problem is more difficult to solve where
we actually saw Geoffrey have a
long-term problem with his Bishop on f8
in the earlier Berlin yep and that was
really a really a problem for him he
never got developed he seemed to try
different ways and it just wasn't
working so I'm wondering are we gonna
see like the same thing happened with
his Bishop on c8 now well the key will
be after Bishop e3 how quickly white
gets that F pawn idea that you
highlighted because if we start looking
at a line like let's say B 6 and even if
white plays rook to e1 check King e8 if
I can get Bishop d7 and c5 and unwind
maybe in a typical Berlin fashion and
indeed Geoffrey goes for b6
yeah it can white just move the knight
from the f3 and then drive the F pawn
that's and we're getting exactly kind of
the line that I was
just predicting and I think I think
Maxine well we'll likely find a square
for this f3 night and try to shove the
f-pawn right but we're gonna we're gonna
see because I I mean III played some of
these positions as black and I initially
I want to like black I like the idea of
of that 996 kind of causing this
dysfunction for white and holding the f4
and d4 squares but but maybe I'm uh
maybe I'm just being biased to the
bishop pair you know I love the bishop
here yeah Danny the the the Berlin
endgame is extremely complex I mean I
don't profess to have a deep
understanding of it either
but it's the type of thing that's really
easy to miss evaluate ya face value like
you look at it you might just like the
bishops that black eyes solid but when
you're facing a guy like Maxine he can
put such incredible pressure on a
position that looks very harmless that
you really start to understand why these
top guys play the position for white
right as look at this position Knight
goes to f5 and maybe pawn to c4 f4 f5 I
mean I like this be not like that have
been better right Knight h2 is he's
gonna play a Ford f5 he's got the he's
got the Bishop I'm sorry you got the
other night coming into g4 so but it's
you know it's it's a dynamic Berlin
ending right here we are we're trying to
figure it out we're learning along with
the fans really because this is this is
theory that both these guys know better
than us and and the very least we can
kind of highlight the imbalance for
everybody so that when one side wins you
know what they did well right when white
wins these games it's because he used
his four on on three majority well and
black couldn't quite get the activity he
needs and if black comes back it'll be
because at the right time the bishops
get active and and gets counter play so
I'm liking white more and more too now
that I see this plan from Maxime I've
really liked this night h2 Tai Chi for
ya one thing I can say is I think
Jeffrey's gonna drop his bishop
potentially to c8 if he sees the knight
come in to f5 and we might we might see
that Bishop on c8 kind of hit these two
slightly maybe awkwardly placed Knights
on at 5 and g4 right if he was to
continue with met f5 and F for basically
the - bottom Geoffrey yeah I think the
move that bothered it was that for ya
that's why strong movie etta prevent f4
and of course if the trade happens
everybody blacks gonna be taking with
the H pawn and and really holding this
f4 move for the rest of the game so so
max team doesn't want to make that trade
he plays Knight f5 but I don't need for
yeah I was gonna say Bishop before is a
fork right hits the knight on f5 and the
pawn on c2 I'm wondering if I thought
for a moment there there was some really
nasty stuff like Bishop takes G v g7
Knight f6 exactly or even 8 on d8 right
Bishop takes Bishop doesn't does it work
because the bishops on e4 hanging there
with Knight f6 check so Bishop g5 start
with 97 and then Bishop takes g5 and
then Knight f6 check picks up the bishop
on e4 yeah it's interesting and then
maybe Geoffrey saw all of that and
that's why he didn't go for it cuz super
really tricky line there that you just
threw at us and I like it yeah so the
bishop on e4 looked good with the fork
but some tactics coming from white but
okay even as this trade happens here I
mean I really don't think that black is
is is is in the worst Berlin he's ever
had h5 is under fire you know and again
this is this is kind of what you see in
the battle white use it trying to use
that bind the four-on-three to have the
conversation you see but if black holds
his own the funny thing is Knight takes
h5 defends g7 which is which is kind of
kind of awkward yeah and the bishop can
always play bishop c8 if white tries to
play Knight f5 I think that's got to be
a sign there that maxime sacked that
pawn that I don't know that he's gotten
everything he would want because no
nobody have to be extremely impressed
that thinks so far with Jeffrey's play
in this opening and yes we see this
tactic we're gonna see the tactic but I
think Jeffery saw it coming and said
alright we know it now it's just a big
trade and at the end of the line I get
your H five pawns so yeah I agree so
here he's gonna play the knight back to
f6 I expect to guard to guard critical
square like 95 maybe he's thinking about
c6 though to guard both the knight
coming to b5 and the d5 square and well
we saw we saw some magic from Maxine
down upon in another endgame
this one looks arguably a lot more
easy Freddie to play and maybe he even
has his own aspirations here because
that four-on-three
as is typical in this opening doesn't
feel like for us right yep not the best
pawn structure advantage you've ever had
and I was just highlighting that this h6
pawn is week and after the night moves
here White's gonna play either King g3
and we're King h3 I was gonna say and
then just try to run up the board so
it's funny when black want to pawn and
swindle his way out of the worst rook it
sorry the worst Berlin ending you still
feel like White's the one pushing here
ya know you definitely do I think white
has to be a bit careful because the
closer that those pawns get Danny to the
to the fourth-ranked
the more we all have this fear of that
classic pawn breakthrough with B 3 and a
3 and C 3 so yeah white also I can't let
those pawns just creep up the board too
far like maybe it's just C 4 B 5 what's
white really threatening over there g5
doesn't seem to do anything he's trying
to bring the Knight to f5 that's what
he's saying is yeah it's gonna be the
break from play he gets that Knight to
f5 h 6 will be under fire but Geoffrey
still playing actively Knight d5 allows
King h5 though my first end here yeah
maxime plays it but what does Geoffrey
have in store he obviously calculated it
okay so they questioned the blonde is he
gonna play g5 here well if he takes he's
clearly probably gonna lose right you
don't want to allow that sorry yeah if
he takes that five if he takes h6 that
looks just as bad right so no ego in 93
93 though yeah we were I think we're
both expecting the same line and the c2
is under fire the night also guards the
f5 Square from e3 everybody so some of
the things that you just can't calculate
ahead of time are let's say if white
gets this at pawn going up the board and
black somehow goes on a night journey to
try to take all the queenside pawns
right is the knight the pawn and the
king enough to beat the king right with
the knight jumping around over there and
that's that's just something almost
nobody yeah he's not something that you
and I could calculate ahead of time and
really neither good day right which is
why Geoffrey is thinking here and big a
big thing is gonna start to become the
clock here as he crosses under a minute
in just a few seconds and
maxime still has plenty of time on the
clock yeah I think we might see the
counter play come from a five a four and
then the idea of b3 and Knight c4 yeah
me to try their employers make a pass on
their white never wants to really take
on b4 cuz I mean those C fonts are
doubled and they want to you want to
make them seem superfluous so probably
this this plan of pushing the f-pawn and
it's just gonna be the Jeep on is kind
of irrelevant now it's just can black
breakthrough in the queenside or is this
one f-pawn we've seen maxine shove one
pawn off the board Danny and it's been
enough in the past yeah well we're gonna
get a race but I feel instinct say that
blacks should be okay here if he can if
you can get the knight back because a
lot of pawns are falling yeah if you can
bring that night back to e5 the night on
g3 has no control over that's right and
you are making too passed pawns so it
kind of feels really good for black here
this is the line amounts talking about
everybody you can see the knight gets
there has full intentions to just
sacrifice itself at the F pawn and and
they always say the night is the worst
minor piece at stopping enemy passed
pawns so that's why why why can't just
go for that but I think Maxime now has
to deal with the knight coming to even
just d6 yep Geoffrey place it and really
like a huge chances here and he did that
Danny because he saw 92 if then that was
on g3 I think he would have maybe just
left the knight on c4 or maybe gone for
the e5 square but are we just gonna see
Ohio that's longer right there just
giving he's just gonna sacrifice then I
don't have six and in play get me four
and I think this is gonna be I think
this is gonna be a win for black I don't
see why not King e4 and bring the king
to e3 forced that night to choose defend
the Kings side i think i think he's
going king c4 yeah yeah no you you go to
the to the king side well you have to
take that pawn is white yeah and
meanwhile it's just kind of three pawns
against upon a knight probably c5 and
king d3 king c tulips should be winning
for black I think King b3 just first and
King moves in now if 95 c5 defends both
to c7 and the b4 pond right so uh okay
white still has some outside drawing
chances here if you can get the Knight
and King back and
even with take down this I can see a few
lines like night-night d3 in this
position I see a few lines where you
kind of pick up all the pawns and you
have that lucky trick of yeah on c7 and
play on 85 nine seats recheck but I
don't think I think that would take a
blunder because now yeah now 93 is just
met by a 5 the night lacks any sort of
effective moved there the a to pawn
Falls next and now this is a Danny this
is honestly just a very very nice game
from yeah Jeffery he staved off the
position that we kind of felt was maybe
trending toward Maxime in in the middle
game and to do this time and time again
against a guy like Maxine in the Berlin
is super impressive Dan yeah and it's
one of the reasons that Jeffrey's young
has developed a reputation he has right
is one of the strongest young American
grandmasters and up-and-comer right and
even in our preview article for the
World Cup Amman he was sort of
highlighted by Grandmaster Robert Hess
and International Master Teddy Coleman
as somebody to remember his name right
maybe he doesn't make it too far this
year but Jong is uh Jong is dangerous
and he's young so this is a this is not
gonna be an easy day here for Maxime
yeah no this is he's putting the
finishing touches on on some technique
here this is definitely still still
winning for black but at least Maxime
has got the King closer and their job
there's 10 seconds and last yeah
Geoffrey and we've actually seen him
blow a winning endgame I would say just
because of time that that rook and
Bishop endgame in the Berlin last night
my staff member who loves the Machine
tells me that the computer has just
announced a mate in 16 for black so Pete
loves doing that whether he's just
calculating the me yeah yeah I'm sure
Geoffrey's just calculating the mate
with four seconds on his clock hashtag
no big deal but no I mean okay black
should still win but Maxime did make
this I think about as tricky as possibly
and I see two whoa
see 392 tonight see - tricky tricky he's
got to go for that right he's got to go
for it I mean I'm sure it's what he saw
but after night see - King eh - night
before King a three or maybe he's doing
91 yeah of course I think
and now night a3 or 92 and draw Jeffrey
just the truck whoa
no Jeffrey uh where do you guys go wrong
well I don't think it went entirely that
wrong it's just that he didn't have like
for example you even announced there's
made in 16 so I don't think it went
wrong
it's just Jeffrey's letting the time get
a little bit too low and Maxime is being
very crafty in the final seconds he's
just not able to put the icing on the
cake here's Jeffrey right so black was
winning but but yeah with no time on the
clock and we're gonna have our our next
repeat of the day maybe first true
repeat with Jeffrey going back to the g3
but no Nino he says no I'm not gonna do
that let's play yeah a slightly more
open position here but Maxime playing
quickly knows his theory here just like
he does in the g3 Benoni I think that we
can't criticize Jeffrey's strategy of
drawing with white if he's gonna be
almost winning with black that's not
that's for sure that's fair oh yeah yeah
no he played well we're just praising
his Berlin and rightfully so I mean that
was a game that we thought he was gonna
win but but uh but he didn't you know
those games always come back to haunt
you unfortunately in a format like this
where yeah you got to play one game
after the other and no real time to stop
and think about hey what actually
happened there these guys don't even
have the time to really emotionally
cover when Jeffrey maybe knew he was
winning but you know what don't have
time you got to move on to the next game
yeah and has Jeff removed I think he's I
think he's just been completely still he
hasn't moved at all like his when he
blenders his winning end games it's just
right stone cold face and when he's
pushing around Maxime in Berlin as black
no less just the same same exact face
yeah the x-men as they call him I think
that's gonna be a nickname right MBL
maybe currently boasts one of the
coolest nicknames of grandmasters in the
top ten people love it the Frenchman
with three names but the x-ray right I
like that yet for John that can stay
that can stick but what's isn't there
someone in the x-men whose it was like
I'm not very familiar but isn't there
like some sort of rock character like
freeze people and stuff D I don't if the
x-men are so 1990s these days it's all
the Avengers
right I forgot the x-men so no but yeah
you're right I think I think there's
somebody with some kind of superpower
there but all right we have we have only
11 minutes left here in the five minute
portion Amman with a one-point a
one-point lead only four for the
favorite what would you think real quick
we get this lat this could very well be
our last five-minute game how would you
assess what we've seen so far as we move
into the three minute portion well I
think anyone can can say that Jeffrey's
had a very strong showing so far but you
you also have to say that Maxime has had
a decent showing as well he maintains
the lead he's been drawing kind of
effortlessly with black in rice of the
games and he seems to be like maybe
getting a little frustrated with how
much this young kid Jeffrey actually
knows about some of these top top
openings right because he's getting
positions which are kind of okay but
Jeffrey's playing so well that he's
demonstrating he's pretty much as up to
par with the theory as as anyone can be
so I think you're you're definitely
happy if you're a fan of Jeffrey taking
it into the slower sorry the faster time
controls what at maximum also the magic
the magic Danny how many in games has he
saved yeah no he really has I was when
you say was frustrated I would thought
you were first gonna refer to his snack
his snack Hopkins because it looks like
Maxie was running out of snacks here but
no L seriousness I think I think you've
been right about Jeffrey has held his
own theoretically which has been really
interesting but a consistent pattern
we've seen is he's needed about a minute
and a half more to maintain that
theoretical equality right and so I
think that if the time controls get
faster and Maxime continues to push push
the young American and his theoretical
knowledge we'll see we'll see if that if
that continues to be something that
Jeffrey can do with less time on the
clock so yeah but I like I like I think
white here too okay black black would
like to play Brooke to c8 but then there
may have been before okay maybe I'm
wrong too like white because I think he
was thinking of some sort of b3 or b4
move with rotate one trapping the Queen
but yeah I'm not so sure that that's
working
he gives herself
but but before is gonna come in here and
if the night moves the C file is under
fire so one thing is that after before I
thought there was Knight takes e4 but
the rook can come back to e1 FG i mean
b1 check
yeah but 94 and the knight can go to b6
and that queen is certainly not getting
trapped okay but this is the line I was
thinking that might happen with b4 in
Queen c7 so the Queen may not be getting
trapped but okay white has a lot of
counter play coming here and if the e7
pawn Falls look out for mating that
ideas on the Kings side yeah and Queen
d2 very importantly Knight f3 covers
everything with kale g2 or Brooke e3
coming next and whites in the mood to
basically you know gift the Queen side
and say that your e7 pawn and potential
mate threats are worth so much more and
that's exactly what we have to take
before and Queen e7 we're gonna get
those lines and from a practical
perspective I kind of like white it
feels like black risked a lot to go get
that Queen side and maybe it's just
because it's Blitzen it's an easier
position to play white here but you
always get nervous when that King is
gonna come under fire there's ideas like
h4 and h5 here g5 is also the vibe is
also a big move because the pawn on d6
is pinned to the Queen everybody so it's
the same position that I feel like if
black wants to defend all the threats
he's probably gonna have to abandon his
Queen side pawns anyway so I don't feel
like White's in danger of you know this
upon arriving on a2 because right in
that amount of moves he's gonna work
this tray to checkmate for sure right
okay well now he's got to decide am i
okay with training the d5 pawn for the
d6 pawn probably he is because cuz there
may not be other options unless he's
calculating east six I'm on is there
some weird way that ye 695 take f7 and
Queen gives a whole bunch of checks and
suddenly black is in a mating dead yeah
just calculating that myself right you
know it looks like everything was sort
of covered and the knight on d5 can
actually come back to f6 yeah block a
lot of checks there so he goes for this
but this this is looking a bit less
promising for for white white dad but
there's still there's still this h4 h5
h6
plan which you talked about which you
know it looks kind of harmless but
honestly that's an extremely dangerous
plan
well this move Knight g5 clearly
prepares 94 followed by an execution of
the dark square so Maxime has to figure
out a way to stop that you can put the
night on d7 which kind of holds f6 and
and then maybe defend the night somehow
but he was also may be planning some
crafty stuff like Knight takes h7 and
rookie for with who work age for Sun it
looks like there's a lot to think about
here if you're MVL putting the rook on
d8 always you know runs into this Queen
h4 idea with each 7 and DA are being hit
so there's a lot of loose things in this
position well even now I mean the knight
and Queen are kind of confused here
everybody you can't take with the night
because the Queen you can't take with
the team because the knight and if you
play a simple move like b5 I think white
plates d7 and then those tactics that
Amon just highlighted look out for
things like Queen h4 protecting the
promotion Square and hitting made on h7
so you know what will will the Frenchman
be slippery in this one as well right I
mean right now he's certainly under fire
so we'll see if he can wiggle his way
out Queen 85 keeps an eye on the rook
Lonnie one which is quite important
prevents prevents Queen h4 right because
of the rook hang in would check yeah the
knight is also sort of pseudo hanging
because the rook is also on prison on e
one it feels like d7 to move but you've
got this hanging night to think about so
I was actually quite a quite a freaking
move here yeah I think he may have to go
for d7 Queen g5 Queen takes e4 and then
try his hand with the D pawn but likely
that deep one gets him nothing more than
kind of a big trade of the Queen side
for for the D pawn and when we get an
angle in game I actually was recently
looking at these kind of end games
standing where you have one pawn really
far up the board right sort of taking
the attention of everything in black
scan right but black is let's say a pawn
or even up to ponts right it's actually
Magnus Carlsen who always prefers to
take the pass pawn I remember world
rapid world blitz there's quite a few
like model games I was looking at
recently where Carlsen plays these
positions where he just takes the one
pawn he pushes it up the board and the
tactics that you can create around this
one pawn are actually surprisingly high
you can play like
your two pieces doubled on the file and
whoa whoa Knight takes f7 see that at
all we didn't we didn't look at that at
all but it's based on the ideas you were
talking about of the power of the single
pass pawn a creative way also to defend
the d6 pawn here comes Queen e8 Shack
for sure right Queenie a check and then
no d7 also works because after you take
then then Queenie a check picks up the
Brooklyn check I thought he was going
here and then now if Queen to d8 that
I'm sure that runs into the same sort of
tactics we were just discussing wow look
at the Knights under attack but this
looks yeah now this looks a little bit
questionable I wonder if he so what
about Queen c7 here Queens yeah I was
just gonna say Queen c7 look straight
forward it makes me wonder again if
Queen e8 check may have been better than
d7 I mean c7 and if I mean you can play
Queen e8 but you're not really yeah your
best-case scenario Queen e8 is he takes
on e8 you get your piece back and now
you're trying to get enough counter play
against the king to justify Mac seems
double connected passed pawn so I don't
right yeah he's going for that but I
don't think this was the best transition
the American a 5-4
maybe Queen e5 after King g7 so you
place rook at fate and I'm assuming he's
going for that check again Queen e6
check here because actually black could
just play Knight f7 in this position and
that could be quite strong night f7 just
holds everything holds the d8 square
clearly Geoffrey miscalculated and
that's the problem when you use all your
time you really go all-in on this
working and then you know you
miscalculate one thing you're you're
kind of hoots yeah well I mean sometimes
they play moves that neither of us saw
coming I'm on like Knight takes f7 and
we're and we're blown away and then
other times the reason why we didn't
look at it is probably it was a little
bit unnecessary or or maybe overly risky
therefore for white I actually really
did like I'm not sure if Geoffrey
misunderstood or over at or
underestimated the position we were
talking about but that pond all the way
on d7 yeah I really think that that
position could be pushed for white with
this h4 h5 move coming up the parity and
there's a lot of dangerous ideas Plus
you didn't get to finish your story
about how Magnus Carlsen always converts
on those positions but I understood
where you were headed and I agree I
think it's an interesting imbalance to
to evaluate when you've got you know the
extended past pawn and and the relying
on the initiative versus the material
advantage and Geoffrey went for
something a little bit over the top here
I think any move here for Maxime
Geoffrey only has two seconds on the
clock and that D pawn is has officially
been stopped yeah he might even just go
for like a six and b-52d seven yeah keep
the pawns or Queen C six another way to
do it
f7 is uh I mean D seven is falling and
with it so was the game yeah for sure
definitely has to check his time
management that seems to be the
detriment right now he's getting some
good positions especially with with the
black pieces but there we saw finally he
was actually pushing around nvl with
white but I think so far what we're
seeing is MBL's just showing a bit more
class in the actual blitz portion which
is right like actually using the time
and using some of the online fax so
that's kind of surprising that that
that's happening to Geoffrey who's very
good online well this will for sure be
the last five-minute game now in the
next minute everybody we will be
transitioning into our first chess960
game which is always a ton of fun the
Challenger the the underdog will be
getting white as Geoffrey has black in
this game so stick around for that and
then we move into three minute I'm on
and the gloves come off a little bit
more the gloves aren't officially off
yet to use that reference in a weird way
but they're almost off in the three
minute portion right and I think PBL has
sort of said here you know what I'm
tired of losing in the Berlin with with
white so I'm gonna play a classical like
I'm gonna play the anti Berlin and you
has done that so I think this is where
we're gonna see well hopefully from
Maxine's perspective a little more of
his 2800 level in a position where you
can maneuver the pieces it's a longer
game I felt that the Berlin's were
always favoring Geoffrey yeah I mean and
we were I think at first we were looking
at it as you know we've seen Maxine play
a lot of Berlin theory but Geoffrey held
his own he kind of he kind of passed
that test right the 28-hundred poking
and prodding at the young 2600 giving
him little test here and there and he
passed the berlin test so we'll see if
he can pass the Italian minor piece
maneuvering test and that's and that's
like a bit of a feather in the cap that
during this you know large scale match
which goes on for many hours different
time controls there's these mini matches
inside like winning a theoretical battle
or making somebody quit and opening for
the for the remainder of the match and
if he makes
maxime you quit the Berlin for the rest
of this the rest of the match that's
that's a little win for him Maxime just
gave us our first head Bob of the day
and here he goes again singing something
obviously we have to figure out what
he's listening to but we are at the end
of the five to portion this game of
course does count but the total game
clock has has stopped we have chess960
after this a quick break and then three
minutes big game here for the youngster
you really don't want to fall behind
three games heading into the chest 960
and I think if he can hold his own even
with a draw as black reset himself and
then move into the faster time control
yeah the thing is with this game Plus
chess960 next that's potentially like a
two game swing on black I've already a
two game leads so he actually just needs
to steady his ship as I think a few wins
have gotten away from him and then on
the reverse side he's been getting too
low on time so he needs to right the
ship maybe he needs to find a way to
repeat in this position and just calm
himself down repeating as black would be
a little better than repeating as white
I think slightly desirable yes slightly
better but but okay he's done well so
far with black he passed the Berlin
chest we'll see how he handles this
Italian his white nothing nothing really
at this point black has the bishop hair
although that's kind of typical and here
comes white gonna slowly unwind the
position maybe this night on D to Rima
do vers itself f1 to e3 but it really
depends on how black deals with this
night on f5 here because if black trades
it then certainly the e4 square becomes
open all right I actually wouldn't have
played in the f5 yeah so it's kind of
interesting to see that from from Maxine
well the thematic response right d5
certainly a good move there whenever the
knight is there on f5 cuz now white
can't take due to the night hanging so
and are we gonna see like an idea of
either d4 c4 just try to open up the
position entirely or maybe g6 first kick
the night out and then continue in the
center it seems like I don't think six
comes do you really want to trade the h6
pawn for the g4 pawn maybe I mean but I
like your I like your idea of pushing
one of these pawns over here on the on
the in the center and he does too
Geoffrey plays yeah for yeah the nice
thing about d4 is it also just kind of
puts the kibosh on that Bishop on c2
right that's not your favorite piece
anymore once that diagonal officially
becomes closed right and he wants to
eventually play Bishop e3 and try to
trade it but then there's always c4 and
then FN years seriously getting in
trouble maybe he's going to take and
play before I was just gonna say I think
that that's what he's got in store here
and then the d4 square becomes weak
everybody and Geoffrey goes for it
you know the youngsters if anything so
far I feel he's played better as black
man is white I don't think there's any
any other way to evaluate in the match I
mean so if he if he can hold his own
again here is black good sign for the
future for the American no he's played
really well black I think actually just
if we look at kind of the content of the
chest I'm willing to say he's almost
played better chess so far than than
Maxine and that that sounds kind of
harsh but these positions have been good
almost every single game yep with
starting off a bit slowly Maxime had
that really nice kind of I'm not sure if
it's a novelty but definitely an
interesting sacrifice he he brought out
in the night off
but since then I I think Jeffrey's been
playing really really good chess but
unfortunately the clock has has been a
factor and a Maxine to his credit has
been extremely crafty in some definitely
losing positions yep no I think you I
think you assess it well as we talked
about him the three-minute fortune
Geoffrey has played maybe the better
chess maybe only by a little bit but
certainly proven his worth is the
underdog but down again about almost a
minute on time that's been kind of the
story is Maxine being a little bit a
little bit trickier in the time the time
scrambles and and consistently up on
time which which makes it easier to be
tricky and under time pressure so I
liked black again though I'm on I mean
Bishop f6 was played to avoid trades on
g5 after the Queen takes d5 but now now
Maxime has to decide how he's gonna deal
with the obvious threat of Queen takes
pawn on d5 well II for is also a big
threat I'm not know how serious it is to
actually maybe he wants to sacrifice
that rook but you know that is material
and Plus this deep on can't be defended
in a very easy way so I think that black
is just super comfortable you know Don
hanging efore past pawn on b4 and I
think that this any type of attack
around the king is probably wishful
think and one of them one of the issues
is because Maxine was all-in on that
idea of attacking the King you're right
that okay white can't just say alright
I'm to all change gears and get castle
because if he does all of those moves
have been for naught the H file is no
longer in danger and black can choose
pleasantly between taking d5 or punching
the e4 pawn through so so Maxine has to
stay in on this attack and that's why
you play Queen d2 because he wants to
threaten Knight takes h6 yeah he's
really all in on this so much so that
maybe three is completely cast aside
because he's just taking yeah he's he's
all-in as they say pot committed and
we'll see if Geoffrey calculates well
and can convert because normally you
would think once that once you're kind
of there probably black should be able
to hold but but we'll see okay very
interesting he takes before I mean I for
is just screaming at me here am on it's
loud it's screaming Eve or yeah takes
Queen takes d5 you know I love this move
for black because after Queen takes d5
everybody there's a double threat of
rook takes e4 and the rook on a1 so I
think he takes d5 the
is completely hanging on anyone right
like it's it's entirely hanging it's
just like a rope mm-hmm like like just
like a rook basically it's just gonna
resign you just resigned it wow so
amazing how quickly that turned and uh
and the youngster does fight back it's
only a game lead you can see the scores
next to their avatars everybody when we
don't have the score on your screen five
and a half for Maxime Lyon beast four
and a half for Jeffrey X the x-men and
we have our first chess960 this is my
favorite time I love this Danny how much
that fuel I mean that that was a crush
that was a crunchy he just I mean I
don't want to go over top here but he
just put d'Artagnan in his place there
with that here and I mean Geoffrey Zhang
just went to Smashville on on on the
Frenchman there I mean seriously that
was that was a big win and again the
theme continues don't give Geoffrey
Zhang the black pieces apparently no
he's playing so well with black a funny
thing about this position is both guys
can actually they can just castle right
yeah yeah they could they could play
move one castle yep Roka King King drops
on g1 and the Brooke and King would
switch places everybody
I don't think we're gonna see that look
at look at Maxime 93 he just goes and
grabs a point I mean yeah Knight HP but
what in the world right I mean is this
some tilt is this is this a bit much
Danny I don't know Bishop b2 it should
move the Queen and I'm Brooke slides to
a one eventually yep
oh and there's even there's also moving
the e pawn and rookie two maybe even
faster oh right yeah of course I mean
worse yeah actually that is any three or
both moves here to threaten Brooke e2
and uh and wowzers yeah way III and
rookie two is actually unstoppable I I
think Geoffrey just did a little head
Bob there I think he's assessing the
same thing like wait a second I think
he's trying to make sure that the pieces
move that way like it's nine sixties
like wait a minute is this right I just
trap a queen here he goes he goes for
this reminds me of the game I lost an
eight moves to Simon Williams in
chess960
and it was one of those weird things
where because you know we know that
strong players rely so much on pattern
recognition
so when you have a pattern you've never
seen before you just like all the sucker
we do on new six yeah this is not a
pattern that I've normally seen with a
Brooke on e2 I move six that's safe to
say
and look at that he just resigns an
amazing 12 it's there this is ridiculous
like a memory has to know that Queen
takes a two is not playable there he
didn't bother to to calculate that
further because I think even long-term
that he was going to be trapped there
not just by this unusual rookie - yep
well letting the players know that it is
a break time and a chance for you and I
- well - to reflect a little bit of
Monday that was a that was a very we
were just talking about you know sort of
the Frenchman's prowess better in the
time scrambles better in the critical
moments but something we forced out her
to be truth the truth is Geoffrey was
playing very well and he proved that in
the last two games or really Maxime just
didn't play very well at all right I
mean that would that was a plunderer how
often do you see number what is he in
the world now number two in the world
lose in about six moves yeah Danny
that's actually five moves there we'll
put that on record but I actually played
in in the beetle tournament in
Switzerland and they have a chess960
side event there which I actually played
in I ended up tying for first but I got
to spectate a very funny game which was
over in three moves yeah and it started
with the Queen on a eight and the bishop
on b8 and the knight on CA and basically
white played b3 black played b6 white
played like c4 c5 white played f3 black
did something and Bishop before just
trap the Queen so and then you resigned
yeah yeah I was like move three move
four and it was between two GM's and he
just resigned well that reminds my game
was Simon was it was a knight trapping
the Queen on move a but there you go
that makes all of us feel better to know
that even MBL can lose in five moves so
that is if I I'm waiting for stab boy to
confirm this but I'm pretty sure that is
a shortest game in the history of the
speech Chess Championship but here we go
come on we have a tied match head into
the three-minute portion yeah people
everyone is getting getting what they
getting what they paid for and the
speaking of getting what they want let's
remind everybody that this match is
brought to you by master
of course the Kaspari offs Masterclass
coming your way just go to master class
comm slash chess we're gonna take a
quick peek into the trailer and I'm
gonna remind everybody what they get for
this course is a it for this class is a
full twenty lessons by Kasparov we had
Mike Klein on earlier in the show if you
missed it but he gave some back behind
the scenes sort of look into what
happened there and the level of effort
and how they push this bar off to really
reveal some interesting and original
stuff and so that's what you have in
store head over to master class comm
slash chest during the break and Aman
and I take our quick break before the
three-minute portion begins right now
[Music]
check chess is a game limited but it's
not just check stand attacks you have to
be creative
let's convert King g5 king c2 King f6
can be speaking to 17 C 14 to 16 before
Kings the second guessing what lost yes
twin takes the knight f5 and it's a
double attack so let's go back and see
what's the next logical moves skewer and
attraction - mate mate I've been
thinking about few ideas that I never
used what I want to show this is one of
my favourite obliques
it's not about winning or losing but of
course at the end of a day's about
whatever I'm Gary Kasparov and this is
my master buss and we're back the the
players are sitting down and eagerly
awaiting mr.zhang obviously excited
about where the match is right now tied
five and a half a piece everybody you
can see it straight above above their
video their webcams the Frenchman can't
be thrilled with his level of place so
far not just because he's the heavy
favorite but you know really as we've
been saying him on Jeffrey's outplayed
him in in most the games even the ones
that Maxime managed to swindle in the
end yeah Danny I think the the thing is
Jeffrey doesn't really get weaker as the
time gets shorter so sometimes in other
matches you'll have matches which are
kind of closed in one section but maybe
if you're in a Kimura or you like you're
your neppo or something it's Aronian you
kind of expect that maybe he has better
chances in bullet but Jeffrey's a super
strong bullet player and this is just
blitz here I mean this is the same time
control they keep won the tournament
outright to even earn his spot here so
I'm just not sure that he's even less of
a favorite saving the best for last in
terms of the qualifiers versus the
favorites reminding everybody of the
bracket here you have Jeffrey Jong is
the 13 seed that would be like a March
Madness upset you rarely see over the
four seed if that happened today but
like you said and you know I think if we
evaluate all the qualifiers Maxime
really got the toughest one right I mean
he's the youngest I think that just
makes him a little more of a wild-card
when you're dealing with what is he a 16
17 year old future super GM from America
right so if you had to
if you had to pick your lot I don't
think Jeffrey would have been most
people's favorite to play so so Maxime
has his work cut out for him and we have
we have what we want which is an
entertaining match so here we go yeah
and maybe Jeffrey has what he wants I'm
not sure if it's necessarily what he
wants but he's got mvl playing d4 and
that's I mean I always know NBL as a as
any foreign player of course these guys
at this level can play anything Danny
but I think he's a lot more confident in
e4 but he's he's playing d4 for the
first time this match so that's totally
different positions are gonna be coming
totally different than everything we've
seen we've seen berlin's we've seen
nighters if you just got here shame on
you the speech Chess Championship match
has been rolling for 90 minutes we have
60 minutes now three minutes yes what's
going on in these positions Ahmad series
I want you to teach them in here because
I I tend to just like whites positions
whenever they get the a file and the
threats of b5 are coming because the
agents pawn is pinned so what is it that
makes black happy to just in my opinion
just be worse in these middle games
well sometimes here I think white has a
huge advantage from normal that the
knight is often on c3 because the
Knights on D - he's threatening - first
of all he's are threatening to
immediately win so to speak with b5
that's a massive threat so usually black
plays rook c8 yup now there's 93 Knight
a5 and the bishop can drop back to f4
and take the be a square so you can't
actually defend the b7 pawn after a
night arrives on a5 usually what black
wants to do is play Bishop e7 Bishop d8
and then capture the knight on a 5 when
it gets there but yeah basically black
goes for these solid positions ePHI vis
a break that black has later on but I
agree white seems to be always slightly
better in these the only hope black has
is if he can trade the dark square
Bishop so even if he loses the light
squared Bishop by Knight takes c6 if you
then plays H takes and Knight h5 for
example I think black could be extremely
happy with that position right for
example here I like the move Knight h5
trade the bishops yes can make your rook
to b8 to protect b7 but you're breaking
with v5 and I think black is gonna say
if I may not be happy in this mover
though because of the line you're
highlighting when that Knight comes
there now rook B
eight is a move you may have to worry
about because of tactics like Bishop
before is that is that true I mean how
do you deal with you know seven pawn
nail III's I agree with you I think
Knight h5 might have been a slightly
more solid approach by Jeffery right
right yeah there's also like okay you're
only ninety seven there's also this move
which is kind of weird and I'm sure he
will never play it but even be six with
the bishop on on e7 would be for hanging
looked interesting but I think black
should have probably jumped at the
opportunity to play Knight h5 and trade
dark squared Bishop swell he had the
chance
yeah at least he pointed that line
everybody that a bomb was highlighting
is that Bishop f4 was not an option
there because the knight could just
trade it so that whole thing that old
line we talked about really was
potentially critical as you look at the
current position where okay black hasn't
lost anything yet but you start to like
White's chances when you combine both a
bind in the center with a bind on the b7
pawn and okay Jeffery agrees so he's
gonna do the desperate thing you
suggested but I just have a feeling
these six may backfire I mean a six is
falling c6 is weak was how come ya the
the thing is if the B file opens it
probably favors black and I was saying
I'm just gonna say I think he's probably
gonna go for this because the pieces
aren't very well coordinated but I have
a feeling blacks should you know you
should be reasonably happy here yeah cuz
the B to pawn falls right in and Jeffery
goes ahead and takes it right as we say
it so there's gonna be once again to
move minor pieces against the rook and
then somebody's gonna show us the proper
technique here ya know I think I think
we're likely in store and that's a fun
battle whenever you have that kind of
imbalance because usually it ends up
being an instructive victory either way
you've got white right with the rook
control over the seventh ranked happy
with that but we saw what happened when
when Maxime got the two minors
coordinated if Geoffrey can do the same
they're dangerous I expect team d6 here
to try to no I guess I really like the
move for kh3 I think if white setup h4
and g5 that would be like a really nice
control engage three maybe right to fish
or is d4 coming for black is that the
idea
mm-hmm okay yeah d4 so he's decided to
just take it and you
playing against the bishop have six g5
Bishop f6 a strap the bishop actually
but Knight b6
yeah Knight b6 can be played and then
this looks this looks entirely
reasonable for black I mean you have the
the past beep on but I'm yeah I'm quite
sure that that this is okay it's just
tough to definite so maybe Brooke e for
I was wondering if he had time to play
rookie to check and try to grab the H
pawn and get back but I guess white was
maybe playing rook C to there anyway
that was interesting so now he has to
back up so route c4 and then if King d5
then rook c7 so yeah that was nice yes
so he's done this but okay now now I
think white is much happier than than
blackened in these positions there's
gonna be rook d7 rook f6 is his saving
grace I think I think I think one of
them draw right niche off I think we're
I think we're headed for withdraw here I
mean I I doubt that either side hasn't
yeah and they they just decided why even
keep playing this so alright well the
first three mini-games is in the books
the match remains tied and we remain on
the edge of our seat okay back to the
Sicilian back to our Queens HD for a
member magazine I'm not a sig trouble in
that game right EE in that ending that
eventually was the night versus the
bishop yeah yeah no I'm looking to see
if we're gonna see those positions maybe
two knights against two bishops is gonna
go for Bishop d7 or is it gonna go a bit
more standard he does he goes for this
Bishop e7 line again but again everybody
I'm on as he was saying normally you get
positions like this what much more
typical of this situation but maxime got
in trouble last time by taking a
different approach we'll see we'll see
what happens here
Knight was pretty much the position yeah
I mean nicely be a direct transposition
I think yeah I think it made it might
have been nice c3 Bishop e7 should be
five last time but at least now we're
gonna see this idea of giving black the
shattered pawn structure I like the fact
that white gets to trade the
LightSquared bishop in addition to
giving black those pots so no it's a
grain avoidance game this is good yeah
cuz normally when you get to play
against the shattered structure you've
you've lost the bishop pair right so
here you haven't lost the bishop error
instead you've traded off
the bishops and okay even if somehow
these Knights get traded I don't think
White's gonna play Knight takes e5 I
think white can play Knight d4 also
night - maybe night - b5 is in the air
here which is it is a fork after all of
the a7 and d6 pawn but maybe you don't
want to give the double pawns on their
three right but I agree with you it
feels like white got again the slightly
better version of this endgame something
that you don't normally see with the
light squared bishop spell thing off the
board here yeah I'm a little surprised
that MDL didn't start a6 like that felt
like the more cautious way but yeah he's
obviously going to justify Knight b5
with some type of tactics here so I
think he's gonna take and play maybe
five yeah yes or taking if Jeffrey
decided he'd like that pawn he gets a
slightly better version than what I was
first recommending to let black take on
a3 but I don't see why Knight to d5 is
not the move here and yeah Jeffery
agrees and we could be it's similar
right okay it's not exactly the same
game I'm on but it is gonna be a knight
versus Bishop Knight yes is a dark
squared bishop specifically right now it
feels like whites a little bit in the
driver's seat but maybe take what Maxime
is not gonna trap his rook on a to Danny
R okay a 95 rook a to Knight 83 same
motif 93 and a piece on 82 but he's got
a check on anyone
yep very close but okay I didn't expect
this move what's what's up he wants a
for rogue a5 he wanted thinks that's a
smarter way to have the rook on a4
rather than on a - yeah just kind of it
does it does hit the e4 pawn at the end
of the line I guess maybe that's his his
point I can definitely say that the the
bishop plus blacks gonna play h5h for
rook g8 the bishop Plus this kind of f5
d5 pawn mass in the center should
probably be better than the night here I
thought white was gonna escape out of
this a little bit cleaner than then he
did with just trading a pair of pawns
but max even has done this in a nice way
he's forced f3 that might not seem like
a big deal but it makes g2 a lot weaker
yep now when you play h5h for rogue g8
really put some pressure
jeetu so I think this is this is very
good for MBA I think it's it's one of
the cleanest games he's you've played so
far and we we're gonna see Bishop again
tonight but with like I said with the G
file for black with the act of Brooklyn
84 and the open position for the Bishop
Plus this pawn mass in the center I
definitely prefer black in this
situation
agreed Knight a3 is coming though I like
this idea because here you can try for
c3 and and if that rook moves from the
fourth rank perhaps the c-4 square
becomes available but but alright Maxime
is totally flipping the script here I
mean now the Queen side is gonna be one
where black gets almost normal Sicilian
kind of pressure yeah that Bishop on h6
is just such a thorn in your side
controlling so many critical squares on
the diagonal
so Brooke a sit yeah Brooke a6 seems
look at multi-purpose yep yeah I'm a
little surprised that we haven't seen
the moves c3 yet by Geoffrey which seems
to kind of maybe allow King C - yeah you
finally do see it yeah no I do late
though
can I take on e4 here pawn takes e4 a
little Intermezzo I mean it you may have
to deal with taking b4 there maybe he
doesn't even like that transition but I
agree with you that was certainly a
interesting shot now I can play Knight
to d5 or came to see - although I'm just
noticing that potentially when you take
on e4 as black rook h3 for white might
be the bad counter play you don't know
yeah yeah a swing at the end of the line
would have been a nice idea so maxime
saw that quickly played rook a four but
okay but this isn't this isn't the worst
for white I mean you've undone weld the
e pawns but you've maintained D file
pressure which means the d6 pawn is
still under your right under your scope
and and you can play king c2 and night
to b5 and we still have also you've also
kind of once you played this c3 more
that's very important you bring the King
to c2 and these Brooks on the a file
start to feel like they're not doing as
much as they good right okay but the
theme of time for us
we'll be one here and we we asked that
question in the five minute portion with
Jeffrey consistently down at least a
minute on the clock in most games
how would that translate to the
three-minute portion and we still have
we were talking about it so we can focus
on the X's and O's as we should be but
if this position remains unbalanced and
you just take another 30 seconds off the
clock for each player's then you have
real problems if you're Jeffrey yeah
yeah no there's there's a few moves in
the position maybe five is the easy one
and it forces black to play rook a six F
and F 4 F where's a is a nice facial
move there key everybody's it just opens
up the fifth-ranked at black pushes or
takes and the f5 pawn Falls so so Maxime
says no thank you but but now I don't
think he I don't think he could have
taken with upon there although he wanted
to just because rook d7 would win
everything on the seventh ring right no
so this is very good for for Geoffrey
now take a look at those pawns isolated
isolated isolated isolated this is maybe
a positional positional show by by
Geoffrey 94 and the broken game is even
amazing yep
for cage 3 is his idea with rook d3 this
is time tells us as it you know we just
highlighted it but the difference is now
only 15 seconds right time tells us that
Maxine Maxine wasn't quite happy with
how the last few moves went tried to
think his way out of it I think 94 yeah
I think that there's there's no way you
can play that rook endgame even thinking
b3 here doesn't that ask a pretty tough
question to the rook yeah yeah King b3
and a d5 is you know just losing tonight
f3 so so he goes Knight f3 first I
wonder if King b3 was slightly more
accurate there but he's still a little
better you can you can even play King b3
now and that she to pawn is gone unn
take a ball due to the fork on h4 right
I think I think here Jeffries doing that
thing Dani where he's letting his time
get a little bit too low comfort yep
he's gonna well is he gonna go all the
way maybe no he I think he wants to take
the draw he feels like it might have
gotten away from him with that
Oh g4 and there's no clear breakthrough
but that's a little bit sloppy I feel if
she played your king b3 move Danny that
that would have been a serious try yeah
it's easy to miss little Intermezzo
'he's like that in between moves from
the forcing lines and her time pressure
but I agree route King b3 was maybe the
last chance but okay you know what we're
seeing here this is this is about as
close above match as we've had overall
in the first round of course nothing
compares to this point to the giri so
match last week Aronian smash with nepo
was also super close but but really
really back-and-forth games here and
equal chess overall by both sides yeah
and again you can say that he is
repeating in these positions but at the
end of the day he's kind of out playing
MVL and then he's repeating because MBL
is like very happy to draw so right it's
it says good things about the the
content of the chess right maxime
shifting in his chair there taking a
deep breath and and really zoning in i
think he knows he's in for a battle here
and needs to kind of pick up his game
and try to get a game or two lead here
before they go to the bullet because
even if you do like your chances in
bullet as you've already said Geoffrey
is not gonna be getting any worse in
bullet we know he's a great and very
very quick thinker there but also you
just don't want to be in the bullet
within a game or two because anything
can happen yeah it's too unpredictable
for someone like MDL to you know say oh
I'll just win the match in the bullet
section I don't think anybody goes into
these speeches matches thinking that
that's a reliable way to to close a
match up the coroner wants to take a
lead
hey kar Nakamura saying in the chat now
watching the show live that he believes
MBL is the huge favorite and bullet
feels like Maxime is is the only player
on the level with himself and Magnus and
bullet but so we will see I think again
that's what makes Geoffrey Zhang such a
tough Challenger cuz he's that young
right and you don't know what these guys
are capable of so I don't think it
changes what we were saying either way
that the bullet is not something you
want to be super close when you're the
heavy favorite right but I have played
both of these guys online in blitz and
bullet but MDL is a
extremely strong bullet player he's he's
played on on all the platforms and he's
been around for a while so I definitely
see what what nack is talking about when
when he says that because he he competes
with naca and you know there's not many
people who can't even say they can't
write all right well right now he's got
to compete with the bishop on g5 because
he doesn't know what to do with it he's
either got a trade on f6 and gives up
the bishop air or tuck his tail between
his legs again I mean we've seen
Geoffrey do just fine his black if this
was a bullet game Danny maybe you you
consider something like 94 yeah I was
gonna say it this is a ball game I play
94 but you know how I play yes oh I play
94 instantly but okay he doesn't go for
it let's just show everybody the fun
times that might have happened in a line
like this where white has mates on h7
and all kinds of pressure but likely not
a good enough sack to justify it
so Maxime backs up the bishop I didn't
think it was so bad like he's even going
back with Bishop g5 I honestly think 94
was okay there yeah it doesn't look that
bad because you're planning to play rook
t1 yeah and and some stuff there but
well now no it remains the bishop on g5
meaning if black does there's even
threats of Knight to d5
okay Jeffries calling your bluff we're
gonna see some fireworks in this game
we're gonna find out if the SAC is good
enough yeah because there's there are
other moves as well like if the rook
moves there's maybe even Bishop d5 and
you can't take the bishop because of the
same mate yep I know for sure that is
this is not necessarily winning for
white or anything so it's one of those
things where you play it as black you
capture the bishop you know you're doing
the right thing but you still have to
justify it and it's very tricky
well Knight b6 seems like a really
strong move there because it guards both
d5 and prepares Bishop f5 which would
have been a super useful defender so
maxime plays Bishop b4 but here comes g6
and I gotta be honest looking at the
body language of the players that you
said before I mean the X Man is just
cold he's ice-cold here hasn't moved at
all I think Mac Seamas he shook his head
a little bit it wasn't one of those it
wasn't a classic nakamora look number 11
where her car was shakes his head but it
was a it was definitely a Mac seemed
kind of like one of those quick shake
off not necessarily thrilled with the
approach he took here but he's gonna do
his best
yeah yeah yeah these needs to splash
some water on the face needs to splash
some water on his face or maybe switch
up the snacks so is he just gonna bring
the rooks in I mean he's got to activate
one of his rooks at least rook c1 or
rook d1 I think almost plastic plate
unless he's calculating some sort of
killer blow here yeah like Bishop takes
g6 the issue is black is black is
threatening Queen f8 here right I mean
any trade helps black now because cuz
you're up a piece so Queen f8 is a move
Bishop a5 is also a move oh wait here we
go Knight takes f7 Bishop takes g6
coming yeah but Queen g7 and black has
three pieces for the road pieces for the
rook I'm gonna guess that that's yeah at
this point I think
Maxine realized like that that attack
was not going anywhere
yeah and Geoffrey just defended like
like you said his body language is stone
cold but so sore his moves like hell
it's not easy to just sit there against
a 2,800 and say and refute his sacrifice
in a matter of moves
well we've seen great play from the
American today among but one thing we
haven't seen yet is him having a lead in
the match so if he wins this game as
black the underdog will take his first
lead of the day and we have a huge role
reversal here not just with Geoffrey
being in charge but also up a minute on
the clock now for kind of the first time
so time for the Frenchman to pull it
together or we are in for the biggest
upset we've ever seen in this format
right I actually thought that Knight to
d7 was interesting instead of E for just
to try to get rid of that really strong
Bishop because now I feel that black has
some coordination is upon's protected
there's no open files for the rooks and
it's just gonna be a matter of time
before he maneuvers the pieces to the
proper square yeah I think I think 96
here okay sorry 96 95 check but Knight
f6 Knight f6 followed by bringing the
whole point of moving tonight was just
so I could bring the rook over to the
Kings side here it comes
and yeah it's hard hard to believe that
those pawns are gonna be enough to
justify you our town literally you are
down three pieces here I mean this is
one of those sessions where black just
starts looking for ways to give back one
of the pieces to get a whole bunch of
pawns right that's why that's why white
didn't play just g4 there everybody
Jeffrey would have chopped on g4
instantly and and still had two pieces
to spare
so right now Bishop at Bates nice as
well it forces g4
you want to try to force the pawns to
move even though they advance up the
board with three pieces you're not
worried about them queening so when they
advance you're actually they're just
becoming bigger weaknesses yep and the
pawns can't push now right you pushed
the Jeep on to g5 you allow Knight h5 if
you push the H pawn you allow Bishop h6
check so black has just kind of primed
all his pieces - to make sure those
pastors can't advance and now he can
start his own his own job on the Queen
side Bishop e5 threatens 9 c4 I think
this is just a matter of technique here
I mean a maximum doesn't even really
have enough time to get anything going
so yeah all the puns are falling in once
once black plays Bishop c6 here which
I'm assuming he's going for it doesn't
feel like there's any breakthrough 93 to
have 4 and it looks like cruise control
yeah Bishop c6 there's just no way for
the h1 rope to get into the game and
once you bring the Knights of f4 it's it
seems like that should be enough the
Brooke might even swing to d8 here yep
there it goes and the mating net is on
game on he's gonna he's gonna push the
pawn because he's gonna say alright you
better make me otherwise this is my
last-ditch right I think mate we'll come
on rookie - I think it's just I think
you should be enough yeah yeah roof d2
you may even be looking at Knight takes
e4 here and getting the bishop ball but
rook T to everybody King III would walk
into mate King out either Knight or
Bishop takes e4 is tempting but you know
that's a sac you have to calculate and
there's an H pawn a couple squares from
being in Queen yeah well and he's got
twenty seconds now so maxime to his
credit we've seen him slip out of things
before all right
I like Bishop before it feels like I
mean where's the mate right this is
where you start feeling like the chess
gods are not on your side if there's no
checkmate here yeah I think Knight G
Louise an interesting move rook g3 also
I'm sure Geoffrey we'll figure out
something the knight is maybe gonna come
from he's got he's got a got a knight
Knight d2 coming right
ninety-two and then kingi one and where
is the mate I'm just gonna run all the
way to the Kings side or sorry the Queen
side yep but it's there's this mate yeah
right there and and we come first our
first lead for Geoffrey's young in the
match and this is assuming the favor
pulls it together here it means we are
definitely in for a close one because
the Challenger has shown he is not going
away and Maxime Maxime is got his work
cut out for him
and we actually have I mean that was
that was a really nice meet but it gave
him the first lead and also we have him
not high rated now then then MDL for the
first time so finally they've swapped
ratings so to speak yeah this is this is
amazing I mean you and I expected I mean
what people probably thought it was lip
service when we started the match and
said that sometimes the underdog matches
are the most exciting but we expected
this to be a fight I don't know that I
expected Geoffrey to be up by a game
with only you know a little over an hour
to go in the match but but we meant what
we said this is this is gonna be a tough
one yeah Geoffrey is I mean he's one of
those guys Danny I played a few
tournaments with him I remember I was at
the millionaire tournament yeah and he
was playing a tie-break to go into the
sort of millionaire Monday section and
while everyone else was sort of milling
about preparing maybe in their heads he
was way at the back of the room by
himself and he was like playing against
himself he was like playing through a
Kasparov game from the past or something
the guy is just like computing chest at
every second of every day he's really
talented so it's actually not a surprise
to me that he's doing well but it is a
surprise that he's doing this well I
mean he's now he's winning the match
well he's gonna have to compute his way
out of this one though I was just gonna
say as we were talking it looks like he
got himself in trouble he's back back to
being down on time and Maxime swindled
something in the opening here that I I
missed because now he's won this pawn on
e4 and I don't think white can just take
back on e5 not because of c3 but moves
like rook e8 would be a serious problem
if I played Knight takes e5 right so
so we'll see how how Jeffery gets out of
this one but the Frenchman might be
looking destroy Harry I don't know about
a three seems seems like in the worst
case black can always take on c3 and
just like f6 right say say you know I'm
just gonna have this amazing pawn chain
and I mean is he up a fight he's up one
pawn yeah I don't know why white didn't
just defend that Bishop d3 last turn or
Bishop d2 something like that well I
think he was worried about the let's
head over to the analysis here I think
he was worried about something on the
Kings side because black had gotten this
really far extended H pawn like if
Bishop d2 are there moves like Knight h5
coming in to g3 maybe not maybe there's
well the thing is Danny the 94 also goes
to G yeah anyway right same problems new
squares except down upon okay well you
know it's funny I don't mean I don't
know that it would really be the case
but emotionally you have to be feeling
pretty good Jeffrey's hiding it well
with that Stone Cold Steve Austin face
but I think after winning that last game
taking his first lead in the match
possibly he he let himself go a little
bit the beginning of this game because
because I mean now he's under a minute
and maxime almost has as much time as he
started with so anything I can I can
relate to Jeffery definitely not being
up in a match against mvl that's not at
all how I can relate to him but when
when you're in a bad position Jeffery
tanks just like me like I use all my
time really trying to just completely
solve all the problems at once yep and
he either like has a miracle and solves
them or he just compounds his his
predicament by being low on time as well
so he doesn't really offer himself any
practical chances later on in the game
because he's always so low in time for
trying to get out of the mess that he
may find himself in in the opening so
you're totally right it is it is
something that as well as things you
admire guys like a carver for right you
just noticed that they tend to have a
sense a little faster when they've
screwed up
right when it slipped from them and they
just say well time to play fast and
that's why they end up swindling their
way to more victories from bad musicians
than other people do and as you and I
are on camera here looking at the
players we got a couple of beards and I
want to remind everybody about the beard
contest because it's actually
doing pretty well if you look up the
hashtag speech s and look for the
Photoshop contest add a beard to me add
a beard to my face that rivals them on
and you get a one year diamond
membership if we choose your photo no
surprise Anton's squared me is is there
along with many other of the Twitter
givers out there so anyway check out
some funny beard photo contests on
Twitter if you want this this matches a
bit of a mustache Paulo Jeffries gonna
hide it but he's he's got a little
mustache there thanks him he's got that
coming of age you know coming of age
kind of mid mid teenager awkward facial
hair I never got out of that stage I'm
still in the awkward Caucasian facial
hair stage and you are not but anyway
let's what's happened here the center
has opened up in a way that dear Lord
completely backfired for black we're
losing her focus here at the summit I'm
sorry I completely backfired for white
now black is the one really in control
well black always was the one in control
right he was yeah yelling earlier and
this so this is kind of by the book I
would say the only thing is that white
has those practical chances of the fact
that the g-seven pond is hanging the
night on 85 is loose but I feel in these
positions that you aw you're always
happier with any type of mess that you
can make in the position and here at
least the night on 85 Black has to think
how is that pleasee gonna trap it he
wastes some time
meanwhile he quite slowly trading pawns
off the board he's trying but I think
this is gonna be a VLS game yep well I
think about nvl is that when he's had a
remote advantage
I believe he's done a very good job
converting it in this match Jeffrey has
gotten a lot of advantages and not
converted all of them but now he's
losing the night now it's just with the
highlight that the night can't even
retreat everybody because the policy too
was pinned and so that's exactly why the
game was sorry to cut you off ya know
that's exactly why the game was about to
be resigned because that night you said
it wasn't in trouble immediately but I
don't know if I did eventually get
himself in trouble and yeah that was
easier than we thought
the Frenchman strikes back the match is
tied once again and we're back to the
Italian this is this is back to some
stuff
that you know Carlson car yakin almost
giving some World Championship memories
here with the ANSI Berlin sand and all
that stuff so the Italian game a Jeffrey
played the last one really really well
yeah we have to say so I'm sure that he
has a little bit of confidence going
into this one and you just feel that
both sides are really striving to play
their best chefs you know people
sometimes talk about in the online
format how much of these guys are gonna
fool around and hide preparation that is
this has been the anti match as far as
that goes right this isn't a car knocker
more a double Hedgehog here this is a
every single game here has been one that
you know maybe not theoretically
relevant at the highest levels but has
been I mean these guys are trying to
play good positions I think MBL's taking
his opponent very seriously and Jeffrey
Jeffrey wants to pull the upset yeah I
mean I'm not even sure I'll have to
investigate that sacrifice that MVL
pulled in the night or but I mean you
might have been saving that one for
Carlson he's like you know what you know
what Jeffrey I'm gonna have to have to
put you down buddy
I'm gonna have to give you the night
takes e5 special so you clearly not
saving anything yep and just their
demeanor now I mean the time they're
taking in the opening here is like it's
more than just time of figuring out the
position you can tell they're trying to
recall what they know about these lines
where they want their pieces and and now
Jeffrey is has gone into a bit of a
thing cuz he's got to figure out how he
wants to deal with the d3 pawn does he
want to bring the heat on the D file
here does he want to win the bishop pair
take on e3 yeah big decision and again
this night 96 is also anyway sorry go
ahead
no I just see myself like just tanking
it as such an unnecessary position where
a lot of moves are okay and because it's
blitz that's probably what you should
make is just trust your instinct move
like rook e8 that's maybe the first move
he thought of right but but shouldn't
matter yeah I took a minute to play it
so well you see here you see your own
time management and Jeffrey and he sees
a little bit of himself and your beard
so that you know everyone gets along
here no but I agree with you I think
overall okay it's a very close
match and we can't begrudge chef first
approach at all at this point but you
know if there's been one overall
assessment of his his deficiencies it
has been how he's managed his time
so we'll see see what happens here but
you know I think he's I think he's got
an approach that he feels very
comfortable the online setting just like
someone like you does and remember you
don't play as much increment as these
formats have and we always talk to the
players afterwards and you know yourself
oh wait are there tactics here bishop
nation is 65 and Bishop takes h6 he
doesn't go for it you know we always
talk to him anyone one thing they always
say right is how the increment sort of
changes things and it forces them to
really play higher quality chess
throughout because the position on the
board is so much more important when you
can't just flag your opponent yeah and
anybody who's comfortable with online
chess against the feeling that as soon
as they see a plus two they're like okay
I'll never lose on time so look if felt
like they can was Bishop yeah it was
really good I think what he was going
for was I think he was gonna take on a
two and it kind of reminds me of
Kuryakin against Carlsen I'm missing
that what was the line I'm looking at
Bishop takes h6 on move 15 oh I'm sorry
I thought you were taking on d5 first
no and then take d5 I feel like that's
even stronger because the Queen can't
even take and if you if you take on h6
first and they take on e4 you take it so
I feel like Geoffrey agreed and that's
why he played King h8 kind of said I'm
not gonna let you fool me twice but
anyway yeah yeah I know I agree that
that that might have worked I'm just
having that flashback to when Kuryakin
whipped up Bishop takes h6 against
Carlsen yeah I think Carlsen calmly
replied and basically just had an
amazing middle position so maybe there
was something there but I agree that I
mean both of our radars went off at the
same time right yeah it's like okay wait
there should be something here and maybe
there was
all right well d4 plate now so again
white is giving up the bishop here this
time Geoffrey says I'll take it but okay
is the pieces sort of unwind here why
it's definitely gonna have more active
control over the center but you got an
isolated D pawn and and a bishop pair
for black so I don't know that this is
the worst thing Geoffrey could have
asked for you know I'll say that I and
in blacks position more time than whites
and I always I always get in more
trouble than I feel like I should in
these positions because that's like I've
got the the bishop pair got this
isolated pond I can even control the d5
square I'm really kind of rooting for
Jeffery here just so that the the laws
of chess kind of work out because
there's nothing wrong with blacks
position no and I was gonna suggest the
idea of f6 where he played it because of
what you're saying that Bishop comes to
g8 and then maybe into d5 and this is a
key kind of instructive of a point
everybody that's normally what you want
to do against these isolated pawns
blockade the corresponding blockade the
squares that surround the pawn and try
to maneuver your pieces in a way that
lets you kind of strangle that pawn all
right okay but here Jeffrey says you
know what I'm gonna go gobbling I'm
gonna let you just took me to that
shameless that is uh what if what do you
guys call that it's a greedy Gary right
they're greedy Guillermo so a greedy ear
mode yeah sorry that was a confusing my
nationalities up the alright well I mean
that's a pawn and at worst-case scenario
if you're Jeffrey you're got an obstacle
at Bishop position and I don't think
I've ever seen the favorite get less
with white consistently than we're
seeing in this match right now I mean
honestly Jeffrey has just played the
most solid chess know he's playing so
well with black I mean he's playing so
well overall but specifically I feel
like he's shining with the black pieces
because I haven't seen a significant
opening advantage for MDL since he
sacked a piece in like one of the first
games of the map right in the knight or
him all right well Maxime does have some
some little chances here there are
threats of Knight f5 everybody so you
don't want to play I don't want to play
too carelessly if you're black in fact
Geoffrey agrees and decides to go kick
that Queen out of there right maybe
ninety six now maybe c6 is also a move
now that now that Knight f5 is not an
option because the Queen guards it I
think black can do a few things but I
think he was worried like if you play c6
I just play d5 and f6 starts to hang and
I think he was a little concerned about
those positions for the bishop on c3
opens up interesting okay showing that
on the analysis board now for the for
the fans at home yep okay but this
transition isn't great for Geoffrey
right I mean you play Queen d6 he was
worried about that but looking at the
time
and the a six-month way I feel like
we're about to see one of those
turnarounds we're now Maxime is the one
playing for the win it's the time I
think why it's actually gonna easily win
this position based on the position and
time like net 9f 5 or K 7 and stuff but
this is like once again Jeffrey played
such a nice game and then the time
Kayson
yep well you see that I mean that's also
to be fair to Maxine that's part of his
overall strategy right that's a nice
little swindle there everybody if the
night takes it Black has Knight takes c3
with a discovered threat of back ranked
mate so that was a nice window by
Geoffrey but still Maxime handles the
tactics and heads into an end game where
he's just got this extra C pawn but what
I was saying about I mean that's that's
part of the issue could give Maxime
credit right I mean he plays faster cuz
he's the stronger player and so yeah you
know that's that's what happens in these
matches this is going to be interesting
because I think with such low time the
knight is really going to dominate the
bishop and we see MVL keep those pawns
on dark squares not playing g4 and
fixing them on light squares yep
Larry Christensen would be proud always
want the night over the bishop when
you're in a time scramble that's not
true everybody that's not advice don't
take that home but Larry Christensen
would agree all right well he's getting
so low on time here yet literally living
off the increment he can handle it
though he can play these positions yeah
now Geoffrey has Geoffrey has played a
lot of blitz and bullet on chess calm so
there's there's no uncomfortable he's
not in any kind of uncomfortable
situation the problem is his position is
just lost so that's the other benefit
that's uncomfortable right okay buddy he
swindled a little bit of a defensive
blockade so far with the King be f5 f5
and maybe 94 yeah he goes for it you
might even play f5 and then okay no he
doesn't want to go for c4 but I thought
maybe he could he could win the
reckoning but the problem with Knight GG
for Amon is if rook takes c3 and you
take f6 the the f5 pawn is potentially
gonna be under fire right yes I think he
was just noticing that as well which is
why he
you can't drop back brings the rook back
this is a threat everybody you can't
take c3 because obviously Knight to d5
check would win the rook mm-hmm
okay but okay I was gonna say this is
okay but then I saw brocation war and
that's a super strong move yeah
back back to the driver's seat is the
Frenchman he's gonna check play king d4
okay I thought king d4 was fine and
maybe it still is he's just playing
tickle on the time pressure hi Betty I
thought Ruki four and Knight g4 seems to
win as well win upon as well but it's
going to be a case for probably
Jeffrey's gonna be able to get one pawn
back and it's gonna be a case of just
there's aa very nice tactic Knight age
six and black resigns that was the
threat we didn't even need to highlight
it for you fans because it just happened
on the board
all right well after after falling
behind for the first time in the match
the Frenchman has recovered that's what
the best players in the world do pull
themselves together and they wins two in
a row and the favorite is back to
leading the match ya know Jeffrey is
letting the time get back against him
once again and is this yes we're back to
the first game of the match de Benoni
and I think nvl is gonna be happier the
benoni by the way Danny gets better and
better the shorter the time is it's one
of those openings yeah that was true
because it takes usually it takes the
right kind of accurate grind approach to
prove the benoni structure worse and so
the shorter the time control gets the
more you're willing to kind of and plus
it I mean at this point Jeffrey hasn't
even played the sharpest lines he's
playing the g3 lines so I think Mac Sam
is gonna be willing to repeat this all
day for sure yeah
in this position he started with the
move h3 that's often to prevent 94 to to
e5 but one thing about this this line
Danny which is kind of annoying you're
not playing efore f45 in the center but
you are giving white or sorry black a
pre free hand at the move b5 because
like bishops on g2 there's no efore
right there's no pieces covering that
square so you're forced to play a five
and a lot of times you can have a bishop
on d3 a pawn on a4 and prevent the move
be fine without having a
a five but here since you have to play a
five it's like forcing the B file open
and that's that's one of those
situations where it's just kind of
guaranteed counterpart and this is the
kind of counter play you want in a
benoni everybody the night whether it
comes to c4 immediately or not I was
just gonna say usually the knight comes
in and you've got the rook on the file
the bishop on the diagonal and all the
pieces meeting on the Queen side for
series playing and ninety four is also
just a strong move in another typical
move here when you have these ponies
wear white hasn't gotten the pawn on e4
so black black is just better here this
is this is a good Benoni I mean this is
I hate saying that because it feels like
an oxymoron but this is a good but Oni
yeah this definitely feels okay I like
what Jeffrey's done with b3 it's gonna
play Queen c2 try play 9 c4 next but
this does feel very good for black the
bishop on g7 is so powerful and as long
as white doesn't get any tricks with
like like he wants to do something I
think with 94 and then there's a little
takes e5 and take some d6 look at that
rook deformer this is one of those moves
where you either come to feel like it
was a brilliant rook lift or you regret
how far that rook wandered away from
home after E for white might try to play
Bishop e3 and cry to try to corral that
thing but something tells me Maxime knew
what he was doing with that move and
feels like his Queen side counterplay
you know threats like a 4 maybe even c4
in some positions are gonna be enough to
justify the rooks position right right
but okay this is tricky now in some
cases the move Queen c2 if you play
Bishop d3 I could maybe play Queen takes
c5 ooh
look at that that is a tactical trick to
be aware of because it's not just the
Queen on the diagonal everybody but the
rook on b8 we'll see if an Bishop d3
kind of feels like maybe a normal move
after Queen c2 so maybe that was in the
air but he's he's kind of changed plans
here I dislike this a lot from White's
perspective because black always has the
move a4 yeah to bring the pieces in
Queen d7 it's going to gain time and get
off the C file yeah now this looks a lot
like your favorite be gambit opening and
that been the Benko right the Queen side
is completely liquidated and normally in
these structures this is kind of what
you have in the end there's an extra
pass C pawn for black in both and both
Benko and a benoni gone well again the
oxymoron that that is but we only have
15 minutes left here in a three minute
portion okay more than that but as you
can see the time is ticking so just a
few more games before we get before we
get into the bullet right and I would
say I mean usually in a Benko there's
supposed to be two connected pass phones
on the Queen set but they've just
evaporated here this looks very good for
for black nothing decisive but it's the
first stage is kind of over where you've
outplayed to sure equality at the very
least and now the next stage where if
you want to win this position with black
you you have to outplay em even further
so right he's going all-in yz-plane c4
and he wants to put that pawn on c3 and
say that with an I Tony for control of
the beef B and C files Bishop on g7 that
that planet is gonna be safe and strong
on c3 rather than a weakness so crazy
idea is Knight takes e4 rook takes e4
Queen takes a for possible I had to play
it on the analysis board because it was
the first thing that popped into my head
but right what's what's going on on
Knight takes e4 what am I missing here
is it Knight c3 and erm is oh that looks
like probably yes yes it looks like 93
is is very important okay so makes me
wonder if it's playable but I actually
don't think so after Knight c3 okay so
that's a key point everybody that the
knight comes to c3 and is defended by
the bishop so Jeffery calculates it well
but he wants to do your idea I think if
Bishop takes then yeah c4 yes so he's
he's striving for he plays d5 to block
that Bishop c3 is played here comes the
knight back to f3 watch out now for
ideas like Bishop before at some point
everybody so the biggest issue again I
think we assess his time currently not
to say that the C pawn isn't a problem
but I think now this this deep on falls
now though this is very bad yeah and
although is the knight be too just
forced to clean off the D file and now
once again Jeffery uses the time to
really think about the position but as
soon as there's like one thing that you
missed down the line not only are you in
the word
they should beer down so much on time
it's almost impossible to come back yeah
I was gonna say I would have just sacked
the exchange as well and an aggressively
open up White's King you could of course
just win it back now with night take C 1
because it's check everybody so there's
no Queen here yeah I'm sure that was
calculating night f4i it looks good
actually a nice Laurie my own I like it
metaphor and then king anywhere Queen h5
Ron you're threatening the f3 Knight and
the h3 pawn yeah and if the king came to
g3 on Knight f4 check at worst-case
scenario you just play check on h5 and
then and then save the queen so okay so
he's going for it we're gonna see
exactly this line
well King g3 the queen hunt was yeah yep
yeah Queen g3 was yep yeah this is what
I was thinking because the only way to
defend Age 3 with your queen hanging is
to obviously move your queen but then
you lose the night so exactly just look
yeah I think this is just over yep I
think Geoffrey uh calculating here as
much he can but knows that this one has
gotten away from him so we are we're
gonna see the Frenchman take control
again right back to a two-game lead
after he wins this and and and alright
not much time left before we get to the
bullet okay yeah just just toying with
it all the way back to AAA here comes c2
cuz why not which by the way threatens
c1 Queen because queen two g2 would be
mate yeah must be must be C to be one
threatens made on h1 as well right
apples Apple we're just comparing
comparing apples and oranges here just
multiple ways to win multiple different
ways to win he gets a queen instead yeah
look at that one final trick for a draw
gotta love that yeah probably just
Bishop e5 and Bob's your uncle
all right well there you go it's is that
a thing they say in Canada Bob's your
uncle
yeah that that's that's very common
especially more so in Canada when the
the likelihood of that being true is
very high right all right well we have a
two-game lead for the Frenchman Amon and
okay a little bit of the steam taken out
of his sails if you're Jeffrey but he's
played well as black so this is a good
opportunity for him to come back only 12
minutes left in the three-minute portion
and we're starting to see to see MVL
surging here like he's starting to put
on the big boy pants Dan yeah I think
the last couple games have been really
good for him like with white and black
he's starting to play a little bit
better I think all it took was Jeffrey
to have like a really convincing win and
he took the lead in the match and then
Andy all was like no no I gotta I gotta
pull myself together here I also got to
put a few more tasty snacks in my mouth
it's getting out of coffee ting yet he's
like Brad Pitt on Ocean's eleven this is
just one more one thing in his mouth
after another
all right well Maxime likes himself to
snack what do we got here we've got a
weird NIMS oh yeah this is looking
honestly like a taimanov yeah now a
little bit more than been an ouzo but
this is not looking like like a very
good timing off for black because why
it's gonna expand with with E for next
turn and just Bishop III Bishop e2 and I
think that Bishop has to go to East 7
and I can just eat for here by ya know
seven fish about right away cuz usually
you know white white gets the D file in
this as you said time on our structure
means that White's gonna be just have a
pretty comfortable edge okay I wonder if
he's if he's gonna go more reserved with
something like III or yeah if he really
wants to push the envelope with you for
yeah I think both are totally realistic
options the the traditional Sicilian
position would be e4 but okay he doesn't
go for that he plays he free so is this
is this really good no case so two moons
ago the Queen was on d8 and Bishop was
on c1 right with when White's next move
really have been Bishop d2 Queen c7 III
that feels
strange seem strange I agree and and but
certainly queen to c7 is a more natural
move for black so perhaps Fisher before
was a little overly ambitious okay he's
gonna play Bishop b3 now and that's one
of the advantages of having not played
ephors you do have this diagonal but I'm
Castle yes okay here we go
yes that's the only way to just yeah I
was gonna say otherwise the defiles a
problem with that Bishop on d3 so we got
to see g4 next yeah that's that's a must
I think we might even see b5 for black
as soon as you can right I mean you do
it too early I might just grab that and
yeah I'll be a palm grabber there yeah
yeah well II 5 is played he's gonna play
Bishop takes chief or I bet if it's
played but I so anyway you can always
change gears and you know he's not fully
committed to an attack right we're fish
about five is coming you mean maybe
right he could switch the positional but
there's your move b5 by by Geoffrey he
thinks it's time now that there's Bishop
e6 and yeah I kind of like it actually
because I were just gonna say if you
actually go for this and pawn grab and
we head into the endgame I mean I bring
my Bishop to e6 and and there's an open
C file and and definitely some counter
play yeah no I like what in the LC he
wants to say alright you take on c4
right I'm gonna put my well I don't like
this at all 67 why didn't he go for that
Knight of 6 and then Bishop h7 I was
just about to say that has to be the
idea III thought that was like I thought
that was like a very very strong idea
you you leave the bishop on e7 and just
like Bishop c3 yeah and I don't even Eve
anything even h5 yeah well like you said
Bishop c3 I love White's position I I
agree wholeheartedly I feel like maybe
maybe MBL just kind of took back on c4
knee-jerk reaction and and didn't didn't
see this idea right okay I know that you
fed Metheny seems-seems wrong but we
can't argue with the position that he's
got because there's h5 coming and
clearly maybe even if you could play g4
next I think that's a pretty strong move
to cut the idea of Bishop f5 so Jeffery
is saying you know what I'm clearly
worse here
I'm gonna try to hang in there with just
defense so g4 comes in now Bishop h4 is
obviously just asking for for imminent
mate with either roped h1 or just taking
on e5 of the bishop but this looks very
good for white just h5 next or g5 yeah I
agree
so missing missing Bishop takes h7 or
not or maxime just trusted in the
potential the attack he's he's still in
total control F now I'm looking for ways
to get something really fancy on the D
file and the diagonals I made I want the
whole thing here right
yeah you want to play f4 pawn takes
Bishop takes f6 you want to sack your
queen I see what you're up you know what
I'm up to
that's why we like each other you get me
there you go yeah that's me oh you're up
to but I think nvl also kind of
understands what you're up to you may
may consider f4 there now that it's a
real pin but he decides Bishop b4 yeah
look at this if Queen e8 is Queen takes
c6 on the horizon yeah yeah I think
that's his idea oh hey does he go for it
you keep playing it he goes for it so
hang on if Queen takes rook da Bishop Fe
what is the move there yeah I was just
gonna say because I liked it but I was I
I was on the wrong board there sorry
everybody but after rook da Bishop f8 if
you take with the bishop I get Queen
takes c4 check like I actually don't
okay so Muslim oh you think you better
take it with the rook and then take it
at 7 with check ok let's let's show that
to everybody so if this had happened
everybody Queen takes c6 if black had
taken because we got to know where the
mate was so he plays rook F a through g8
gets f7 and then check and rook c8 so
there was a mate max zone so the
instincts were right but we second-guess
ourselves just for a second like wait a
minute
but but yeah of course of course the
mate is there full fully admitting I
second-guess myself cuz I started
getting distracted with my teammates
showing me some of these awesome
Photoshop beard examples man of reason
it's got some stuff going on I don't
want to see these I don't really get
Anton squares approach adding kind of a
bee helmet and a bee beard so I don't
know he's usually on another
it but I think unis unis eg on Twitter
takes mine takes my vote so far with the
with the chest beard Photoshop contest
all right well we got a rook ending
where white is in total control and once
again Jeffries under a ton of time
pressure any change I think this is dead
loss the Kings cut and there's two past
pawns and black doesn't have a hope of
even like queening one because I think
you might even resign on that rook a
five but yeah yeah sometimes you see a
move like that and you're like you know
what I've had a net when your opponent
kills the counter play that efficiently
it's like okay all right you got me well
pretty good chance that this next game
starting is going to be our last game
with under five minutes left in the
three minute portion I'm not sure what
the players are doing here there we go
they were waiting to rematch for a
second maybe Geoffrey wishing he could
take a breath here right this is where
this is where things get dangerous right
Amon we talked about this format okay
the underdog took the lead and what's
happened since then maxime has won four
games in a row and pretty convincing van
I mean he's mad I seen his is he's
killing it now yeah in a way of speaking
because he has not just been up on time
it but his positions have been really
really nice and he's it's almost like
the the depth of a 2,800 player can be
felt over a match of this length right
if this match was shorter you know the
the guy who's lower rated more of the
underdog he can come up with the shock
value right here a few things maybe come
out swinging but over long match MBL's
just showing why he's the the high rated
player and the last four games have been
very decisive so if he takes let's say a
nice game right now into the bullet well
into the chest 960 and then into the
bullet I think he's gonna have a great
healthy lead in a section a format where
I think he's the favorite as well a
great showing everybody real quick if
Geoffrey had taken everything on d6 at
the end of those lines to e4 pawn hangs
so for those of you wondering why that
wasn't the case that's why white doesn't
go for that but Geoffrey is gonna take
the pawn now and we are gonna see a
middle game similar to the one we almost
could have had in that game where's
everyone a pawn and went into the
endgame here black this one's better
the first time was way worse for him BIA
agreed I think this one definitely holds
more counterplay partly because he's not
forced to trade queens and he can start
to get some active Sicilian type tactics
with with immediate threats like night
two before currently on the board so so
this could be a tricky one but you know
I agree with everything you said about
about the tricky part about the format
and you know I think that once the
stronger player gets rolling the the
underdog really has to hold themselves
together emotionally to not let the
train run off the tracks right and and
it's you made a good comparison you say
in this match format the stronger player
almost always wins it's like the NBA in
a game seven four and a seven game
series right you just this better team
almost always wins when they have that
those types of they have enough games to
kind of pull themselves together should
some things go wrong in just a couple
games right and I mean there's a
tournament coming up which you know
we're gonna be covering with the help of
chess comm the World Cup berth right
early the format is not a long format so
that plays the exact opposite of this
where the stronger players yes their
favorites but they're not as much of a
favorite in a format like that and both
these guys will be in Tbilisi of course
we're talking about the World Cup
seriously if you have plans in September
you need to make the the chest broad
coverage a part of them because you guys
you guys are gonna have yes or Sarah won
you know excited people are about that
the the great the one and only the
smooth the series not the smooth
criminal' the smooth whatever right yes
or Sarah won one of the most
recognizable and respected faces in the
history of chess commentary that guy
laid he laid the groundwork for guys
like you and I to do what we do right
yeah yeah absolutely I mean that's the
that's the famous lullaby voice that's
right yes or Sarah I'm gonna be
commentating with him so should be very
very fun look at that move guys 985 just
says like you know what you brought your
rook out too early buddy because if rook
takes a three nice c4 check was lights
out so uh he's still up upon but I mean
this this is the the compensation that
magazine was looking for I think maybe
ten games ago when if you play up this
yeah now he's got it so obviously a
slight improvement there I think I went
back and just checked the opening he
brought his knight out to see
and attack the queen of d4 before it was
possible to take on d6 so he made
Jeffery waste an extra move running the
Queen back and that's why he gained a
few extra Tempe from from their previous
game yep and I'm showing everybody that
line there as you pointed out we were
talking about why you couldn't take on
d6 everybody I highlighted that because
at the end e4 hangs but but that extra
tempo black gains because white can't
take on d6 is why you got the line of
mom which was talking about black didn't
have to trade Queens which really
changed the game as far as the counter
play he got now everything came to life
for black so okay it's still a game and
white is a pawn but you just you look at
this position with the King on d1 rooks
on the D and C files and do you think
they're gonna repeat Dani and they'd be
294 these guys haven't been known to
repeat
I think Geoffrey would be happy with it
I think Maxime is taking his time here
because I think he's considering whether
he wants to play for a win right
the thing is though he he is down upon
and you know if he can just get out of
this game he's black you know he's proof
that upon his obvious compensation I
don't see anything really really forcing
for him other than doing that so I'm not
sure he would be so upset with it yeah I
agree especially you know he just won
four in a row now we maybe get two draws
black and now he will get white in the
chess960 battle so a small vertical the
three-two has just ended right so if he
had made that draw maybe like five ten
seconds earlier he might have got
another 3-2 game in there but now that's
right I think he's deciding whether to
just take a draw or not yeah I wanna see
thinking both especially with the time
he's used yep agreed and uh no okay well
he wants more he wants more than than
just a draw maybe he wants to continue
to capitalize on this momentum but
either way we are about to see chess960
we have a three game lead now the
biggest of the match for the favorite
Maxine ba Sheila Groff but but we've
seen a very very equal match if you're
just joining us thank you for checking
out the 2017 speech has championship
sponsored by master class all right I'm
on he went for the win with f6 is he
gonna regret it because now Jeffrey's
not gonna take the draw right he's gonna
play King e2 and then f3 I assume
then night b5 is the idea of Maxime so
he was planning me deaf through 85 I'm
quite sure and 1904 and 93 were both
massive threats and here he comes with
94 no he can't play night before yet so
the bishop perhaps retreats itself but
Bishop okay doesn't have to retreat
itself yet he's just he's just gonna
continue to push the bind is is what's
he threatening I'm Brooke e4 I mean
there's there's gonna be things
beginning like King here soon
he's doing the worst thing that he's
he's threatening to threaten he's not
threatening anything that's one of my
favorite things to do actually it's one
of the only things I'm capable of but ya
know you're right yeah he's threatening
to threaten something but what he's he's
really doing is is putting us in a
position to the kind of question is time
management which is something we've done
for Jeffery we haven't really done that
for MVL now I mean he's actually under
time pressure and as we know he's the
one who refused the draw so if he if he
lets the underdog kind of back into this
let's say Jeffery wins this game that
that's definitely one you've regret
right and then you only got a two-game
lead and and the plenty of polo games
left yeah I think Maxine has noticed
that Jeffery has been very sort of
nervous when the time gets low and
hasn't been planed the best moves right
I think he's just sort of milking this
position in order to you know play
shuffle the pieces and when the time
gets lower I'm expecting that he's
hoping to have an advantage I was just
analyzing Bishop d6 instead of this
because Knights see one could have been
met by Bishop to f4 check and and that's
actually the line that's happening now
but I'm wishing the bishop was on d6
from axiom oh he's got another tactic
he's got another okay I did I didn't see
that
93 is a pretty strong but he just kept
the pressure of f6 was a nice way to
keep the game going and he understood
that with that Knight only one although
it holds the c2 pawn and just keeps the
entire position together it stops that
h1 broke from ever entering the game so
it's essentially playing down a row and
he's using all his pieces to great
effect 93 is just a nice nice tactic to
finish things off and Geoffrey took a
lot of time there and again I feel like
maybe he should have just played it
instantly and recognized that he had
made a blunder he has found a way to
sort of swindle his way out of it rook
the rook th I go here and King c4 and
rook a to
look at this tree house Wow Wow a
strange transition of moves there and
it's one of those we wish we had instant
replay but they work they work into an
end game where Maxime though is still
totally in control and that a pond if
this King tries to run again it is just
it's not enough for white I think that
this is completely losing or from white
unfortunately with that rook on the
second-ranked but we'll still we'll
still have to see some some technique
yeah frustrating if you're Jeffrey to
feel like you swindled your way out of
that combination still to land in a lost
work anything but that's what good
technique is Jeffrey trying to create
some counter play here with that
sacrifice here comes g5 check I think
yep and then take the pawn uh-huh okay
he's he's actually you know can he play
King d6 no maybe not well I like the
fact that he's at least brought his king
closer to the pawns initially I had the
impression that the King wouldn't be
able to reach the pawns right but his
idea is that he's getting the rope
behind the pawn and that's kind of
that's kind of important yeah rooks
behind the pawn in rook endings
everybody it's gonna force Geoffrey to
put a rook in front of the pawn and the
reason why that's bad just remind you of
the basic principle is in this situation
the white rook loses scope with every
advancement the pawn makes and it really
puts the rook in a position where this
rook is completely stuck you want the
roles to be reversed here if you're
white yeah he's gonna play g6 and then
play e5 and I think that's that's enough
not because he's gonna take back with
the rook everybody but because he's
gonna bring the King up to e6 and slowly
but surely white is in zoogs wrong here
I think he's gonna resign he wants to
give some check he wants to play this
yeah give some spy checks but okay maybe
he's not aware it's possible he's not
aware of the overall match situate I'm
sorry in a clock situation and feels
like he just wants to get this game to
take as much time off the total clock as
possible
it looks like he's aware of it now
because that's what happens when
chess960 is on the board and we have we
have new kinds of weirdness yeah now a
big four-game lead by MDL eleven and a
half to seven and a half
/ Jeffery and he's got white this time
in in chess and Stacy now I'm hoping
Danny that we maybe get a longer game
than last time
you know what if if one side loses in
five moves again we would be more than
shocked if you're just joining us
everybody the first chess960 game of the
match MBL the 2800 lost in five moves so
so yeah that happened I don't think
that's gonna happen here but this is
this is still an interesting one
whenever you get the Queen's on these
long diagonals right you just start
looking for early batteries and that's
why Jeffery basically plays like a king
side Benko sacrifices pawns just to kind
of aggressively open up the Queen and
Bishop which I I I like that strategy
from a practical perspective yeah it
seems it seemed optimistic but when
you're down for you and he have to be a
little optimistic yep
so he's it's important to say that white
actually can't Castle kingside or Queen
side for a while right with the nature
of these of Liberata these positions
because unfortunately you need the other
rook on a a to go to be eight and the
the coordination is not really there and
it's because of that again why I kind of
like blacks practical approach although
now if white is getting control over
these dark squares and then that that
might change my opinion there but if
what if black h5 is nice yeah yeah black
is five five
here comes dxe5 I can I can see this
this working out but again upon upon is
upon he's gonna play off six and if I
think black has very reasonable
compensation we might see tonight we
might see castles here you could Castle
castle kids that would be would be very
surprising I'll say yeah I guess it
doesn't work so well when your Queens
stuck on h1 in fact after 94 you start
to think the white has for us of g4 so
uh that in fact maybe that's what we see
now g4g four looks like what the doctor
ordered to me yeah I like Bishop Bishop
ei g4 yeah he goes for it and I think
after Knight g7 you would just even
played Bishop g3 I don't even know if
you have to take the d5 pawn you know
just kind of recored innate remove your
bishop from that file and I start to
like white takes d5
threatens night take z7 Shack which is
kind of nice right I would I would just
take that pawn that's a plus for sure
yeah I think Knight takes d5 is is it's
the first time we've actually seen that
the chess960 game get played out because
we didn't see maybe how good or bad
these guys were at chess960 from the
writers game but now we see you know
when fel plays the the actual game he's
he's pretty ya know that eight that
Queen takes a to move still kind of
shocking to me
but yeah Jeffrey's in trouble here I
guess the pawn sacrifice I liked is not
looking so great in fact the main reason
I didn't yeah well the main reasons like
did it was to get a more active Queen
and Bishop and if anything the opposite
has happened here White's Queen really
dominant in the middle of board so yeah
so big problems if you're facing a
five-game deficit going into the bullet
portion the was very bad eventually he's
got a move that rook and just get
canceled but like you said this is going
into bullet with likely a five game lead
look at that
castles short he almost gave a little
smirk of their nvl did I think he kind
of knew that the fans wanted I think
castles King side was almost unnecessary
Amon I think white could play rook f1 I
mean it's such a strong move with work
f1 threats of g5 and then castle long
but Maxine wanted he wanted a lot it's
fun I mean to three king all the way
right across the board like that no the
knight 96 is also gonna be fun and it
looks like it might even trap a rook on
d8 so unfortunately not ready to call it
yet but this is looking more and more
like the Challenger has really he's
really you know what he did come on he
poked the bear that's what he did he
jumped he almost shouldn't have taken
the lead in the match right you should
have continued to maybe just hang around
but he poked the bear if you're just
joining us everybody
Geoffrey Zhong was up by a game about 20
minute maybe 30 minutes ago and Maxime
has now won what's going on he's won
five games in a row and may be about to
win his sixth yeah the thing is people
have to remember that's seven and a half
the Geoffrey had that used to be leading
the match yep that's that's how long ago
it was you
seven and a half to six and a half yep
and then all of a sudden and BL just
just took off yep well that Queen could
go to a seven that would be that would
be nice but I don't see an easy way to
do that
I'm guessing Queen see four there's just
a seven yeah okay what what happened
there just I think Mexi might be
regretting this whole castle short idea
suddenly our predictions of Maxime
winning his sixth game in a row or are
looking well he's he's who dear is he
gonna play Queen c-5 I think he just
yeah just play yeah look at okay Maxime
kind of gives it the old shrug and takes
off the headphones well that didn't go
as planned this is what what that face
says that he's just annoyed too I mean
he's really happy obviously with how
it's gone recently he still takes a
three-game lead into the bullet but yeah
he can't really be pleased with that
that feeling right that going out on a
loss yeah and he's lost the second
chess960 game in a row different fashion
didn't lose in five moves but definitely
blew a completely a good position
everybody if we back up to the moment
where we talked about what rook F 1 I
think I think we're good yeah it's
delicious we said you couldn't you
couldn't resisted but this move
threatens g5 there's no issues with the
king and white can castle long so I
think that's where he blew it but I'm on
long story short
we still have a three game lead for the
favor head into the bullet and what do
you expect us to see here yeah the the
bullet portion is going to be well
obviously matched deciding that's not
always the case but here it's been such
a close match through the 5-2 blitz
the score was five and a half five and a
half but honestly that was Jeffrey's
best segment and he should have
realistically been leading after that
Porsche and then in three two I think he
also kept up his his stamina till about
the midway point and then nvl honestly
really started to kick it into gear he
started playing really well really fast
and was starting to get opening
advantageous almost every game and then
for the bullet I think a much better
player is MVL than Geoffrey but
Geoffrey's no slouch the only thing is
that the match so far has pretty much
been decided
by Geoffrey's time management yep so we
put him in a time control where
mismanaging that time is almost any
instant loss and I start to get worried
you know well we are we are excited to
see what happens in the next half an
hour so don't go anywhere let's take a
quick break here and get a get a word
from our sponsors get some sneak peek
and play the trailer of Garry Kasparov
master class coming out make sure you
head over to master class comm slash
chess big thing I want to highlight
again is the level of the instruction
that Gary gave was really targeted to
what I think is the majority of our
audience not necessarily advanced
tournament players but people really
aspiring to take their game to the next
level that 1,200 to 2,000 really I think
most the content is probably 1,300 to
1,700 let's let's take another sneak
peek at the trailer as the players
continue to come back to their to their
chairs and we will start the bullet
portion in about 60 seconds
[Music]
check chess is a game of amenities but
it's not just check stand attacks you
have to create let's cover King g5 King
c2 king of sins can be speaking yourself
you see 14 to 16 before Kings a certain
racing boom
what was yes
Quinn takes the knight f5 and it's
double attack so let's go back and see
what's the next logical moves skewer and
attraction and this mate what an amazing
mate I've been thinking about few ideas
that I never used and what I want to
show that's one of my favorite obliques
it's not about winning or losing but of
course at the end of the day it's about
winning
I'm Gary Kasparov and this is my mustard
I couldn't have said it better myself
Gary at the end of the day it's about
winning or losing and we're gonna find
out who's who's gonna win or lose right
now Jeffrey Jeffrey shaking it out
shaking it out but you could see his
hands they're reminding himself to be
fresh have a little fun and we've got
our first sort of funky opening our
first no on a theoretically important
blitz game of the day which is saying
something right ya know we finally get
the bullet section is gonna loosen
everybody up personally I like these
these bullet games when you play Bishop
takes f6 really early and you double the
pawns because sometimes bullet can be
such a simple creature just give your
opponent pair of double pawns and
sometimes that's enough to say that you
have an advantage but just an easy
position to play well it is all about
getting an easy position where the plans
are simple and playing in stubbl pauses
is often pretty straightforward
well they a weird weird opening yeah
with this b4 I think that's the
orangutan last time I checked my monkey
openings but now are there other monkeys
I thought there was a baboon maybe that
was just a nightmare I had once but
there is there is there is at least one
monkey opening and that's what you see
here everybody would be for but I
personally like black in these positions
I mean we you were saying what you said
about the easy to play against the
double pawns but I love it when I get
the bishop here this early and I think I
think FAL is already saying you're not
gonna shock me with some sort of weird
opening here yeah and take a look at the
ratings by the way I mean Geoffrey 29:21
just going to show he's like no slouch
at all
yep in in bullet of course and
a bit higher rated even pushing 3000 but
this this is going to be a very
competitive section I think yeah you
tend to have that tier of bullet players
you have Nakamura who lives above 3000
when we see Magnus Carlsen play bullet
you know he obviously shows that he's in
Nakamura's class but after that you've
got players like MVL and Jeffrey on
chess comm that are you know any given
day like you said if this wasn't a
longer match and there weren't already
scores on the board I think any given
day Jeffrey might be capable of
upsetting Maxime in an hour of bullets
yes yeah no definitely alright well
we'll see what happens here he's got a
nice position with the Knights extended
on he's got to here how to hold him
together
he's let's go watch that clock Danny
yeah again he's down on time and now
he's down on the threats of black being
ready to give up the rook for two miners
I think he's got to play 95 he just
needs to move it quickly but he just
needs to do that like I know I agree I
feel like he was wrong with 95 I think
he's just lost on time what's going on
here did you think that was a blitz game
I think wait a minute Geoffrey just
thought it was a blitz game it just
wasn't paying attention to the clock
good we we can confirm here his camera
like he's like so relaxed I know the
team always tests immediately on that
because we're always trying to be aware
of it there are any potential connection
issues looming but no Geoffrey is still
connected to the server and you didn't
even blip on the camera besides all the
sudden like oh I just lost on time
that's that's weird
no he didn't even look phased he was
like okay yeah well played game well
played game I'm just gonna go ahead and
let my clock run out here no worries all
right well we have still 27 minutes left
so a four game lead for the favorites
still plenty of time for Geoffrey to
come back and we're really getting some
some mixi some Mick sees that it was
some met some messy stuff here now with
with a French blackall and gobbling the
D pawn and Mike get his queen trapped
over there on h4 there's a threat of
Bishop g5 here everybody yeah you're
absolutely right Danny this is very mixi
position of mixing for sure yeah Queen
Queen on h4
pawn missing from d4 this is
I would say these always turn out bad
for black and bullet right even though
they're it's probably complete rubbish
bye-bye white but yeah I'm always more
scared to play this yeah as black and I
often get into it since I play the
French myself
ya know you gobble a couple pollens
you're like art I can do it this time
and then all of a sudden the tactics
open up in black wishes that no this is
exactly this so rookie five you have to
sack a piece on the top nine dollars 95
56 nonsense everywhere yep and if you if
you play moves like she's six everybody
this night can well I mean then I can
even just go to d4 and there's there's
all kinds of sacrifice tactics coming on
e6 and g6 and and that King has nowhere
to run to
so no this looks really bad Bishop f4
publicly retaken f6 check but okay he
wants the knight on d6 instead likely
because Queen takes b4 at some point is
gonna be an idea and like if this King
comes to e7
okay Queen takes b4 Knight takes D three
Knight f5 double check and then made on
e7 coming him on route c1 it hurts to
see this is Red Rover I think Geoffrey
knows he's up against the gun he's got
to play some sharp openings but I think
the youngster needs to take a breath and
pull himself together cuz he's playing
it too much like a blitz games he's been
playing really really good chess in in
his math portion yep but he's trying to
continue to play good chest yeah when he
needs to play fast chest yep and he's
not like I think this could be a
landslide if he keeps up this sort of
he's almost in this trance of playing
slowly right now right and he needs to
eat nice to snap out of it completely
because when I mean I played Geoffrey
and bullet he doesn't play like this
right no I agree and that's that's why
it's a match right you get those kind of
emotional swings you have the hangover
from blitz right now not like you just
you know log on to chest comm for for a
couple hours of bullets so I agree with
you I think I think that the overall
play of Geoffrey has said that this
match has been a very very close match
but right now right now he's he's under
time pressure before we can say boo and
and that's right I think I think he's
losing a bit of some of his objectivity
because in the last game
you just don't gobble that many pong
give up the dark squared bishop that
that's something you do in a blitz game
and maybe he was treating it too much
like one because if we look at this game
once again this looks like a little more
yeah this is a slice right yeah this is
there was a threat of Knight h6 there
everybody so black has to be careful
about ideas like Knight h6 and you can't
take it because Christmas is what you
want Danny you're gonna play Bishop
takes e4 yep a knight f6 in young age
five or Knight f6 first actually just as
strong it is not there we go Danny this
could be a match they marry the American
has found himself I agree this is a game
that he's gonna win in brilliant fashion
this is you got you got the two bishops
poking at the Kings side Lasker last
year is celebrating at the time yes very
very nice game take with the pawn here
comes Queen to h5 you could oh oh I was
gonna say I almost wanted to go to sac
town right away but alright okay but you
can take g6 here and the point is 'if or
doesn't even work in her mizo cuz she's
seven check wood wood wood fork the king
and rook so I think we just take g6 and
then take on g6 again with the bishop
why is he taking time here gobble I
think he I don't think he likes Queen
takes f6 after that or just the fact
that that that part was is lost
oh no Geoffrey that's something when
he's letting it slip a little bit there
yeah Knight d4 yeah and there's always
Bishop f3 in the position hmm that's
just as well as efore that's
disappointing for for Geoffrey here
comes e4 no you can't play you for now
because Bishop takes d4 but but uh yeah
rook to c2
there's no threats anymore and now it's
like the flip the flip is coming yep
okay f4 was a nice a nice move trying to
get Intermezzo but here yeah I should
have three don't worry baby no no I'm
playing for you oh yeah yeah okay gimme
one is a move maybe baby only moves I
think yeah
King you want everybody that's the point
if you take here white does when the
Queen still very hard to analyze bullet
but doing our best so full o Pontes
that's
we'll move this nasty here comes takes
t2 and then we're gonna take the thing
is Jeffrey he's got three seconds like
he's using too much time and NDL is just
calculating that nice creation while
Jeffrey's time is taking right that's
why he's playing it so fast yeah okay
this is just completely losing fur for
what yep
h6 and king g6 or or shove the a pawn
yeah just just f7 and King g7 here put
the king when I fade yep
you could have easily played into there
but yeah it's over and really again
another another super tough game for
Geoffrey zhong especially that one felt
like one he had in the bag I mean I was
calling I was calling brilliancy right
I'm like the I'm like the commentator
who cried wolf I thought it was I
thought it was over man it was a good
game he was up like 30 even 40 seconds
in that position and we see a VL really
hidden the bullet button and playing h4
h5 he's comfortable okay well I think I
think it's still fair to say though that
we both have seen Geoffrey Zhang play a
higher quality brand of bullet chess
he's playing too slowly like it's blitz
and Anita needs to find himself in a
hurry we're almost heading into
mathematically impossible to come back
territory yeah and the the issue is that
there's no positive trends it's not like
you know Geoffrey is making a comeback
or he's got the momentum nvl actually
has momentum here and it's pretty much
been all mvl - the chess960 games
getting the five to blitz portion yep
all right well what's uh well the
world's in in a bullet isn't it a bullet
rule Danny that when your opponent plays
h4 you never let that pawn reach h6 yeah
that was sort of an unspoken it it is
it's an unspoken rule and whoa
nice work things f2 but there's no
threat it's not I mean of course you're
threatening the knight and stuff but
it's not a check it's not a decisive
tactic so I assume that there's some
call move that can be played queen or
wrote h3 and you know you Castle maybe
next turn I don't think that's enough of
a shocker to put MVL out not at all
well now a2 hangs if you want to get
greedy yep there you go guillermo go get
that pawn yeah this is bullet I don't
think I think Guillermo is about 1200 in
bullet Danny this it's not his favorite
time control yeah well uh black black
hand castle long hair and it's still
still kind of okay
[Music]
so waiting waiting for Owen not a bad
move there either if black can simplify
the position that pawn is looking better
and better and maybe now even King g7
yeah I was gonna say forget about
castling and just it's just gonna be
bullet tactics that that are the end of
him here because he's up now three pawns
that this should be very convincing it's
just whether that 94 move coming up next
causes Geoffrey any problems and there
he goes and things are blunders yeah yep
okay well I think the statue moved I
finally saw Geoffrey shows signs of
discomfort oh there we go he's finally
looking at the ceiling he's really
really not happy with that game and he
realizes at this point it's it's gonna
be like a seven-game lead if he loses
this and he needs all the points you can
get yeah disappointing especially when
you know things are already going the
wrong way you play a good game and then
blunder it away it happened last game
with a nice attack and just happened
there with just a single rook move so
and he's still in this I mean he the
knight to b6 to c4 as an idea and mt5 is
an idea know it black might even still
be better here I mean really yeah I
think I think black is still better for
sure here comes the Knight to c4 and
there's a little bit of a mating net on
the King potentially if he pulls himself
together and wins this game that's a
very good sign for Jeff because he
finally looked really really unhappy
with the I was gonna say be careful if
your way there was a rook g1 check was
now possible due to the night everybody
but other
it would have been made so he wants that
yeah and it's been now now White's
really in trouble having to sacrifice
short of good for for him he he earned
that that one I think he's gonna resign
resign here maybe yeah well big win for
the youngster and just in time for us to
say this match is not over yet okay we
are looking at a potentially epic
comeback but good to get on the board
when you've had a couple games that you
really should have won so we'll see if
he can notice that
maxime changed it up but I didn't repeat
the same line he had played against this
orangutan the last couple times and
didn't want to face that same type of
King side attack knows he got away with
one there well I think Geoffrey may be
prepared this be for mu for bullet just
seems like it's his plan with white and
MVL has played H for last game now he
plays a 584 he says he's clearly in the
stumbling the bullet mode right yep okay
but I like I like Geoffrey's opening
here I mean as much as I I like to pick
on the monkey openings I feel like this
is gone pretty well for him you can play
it no he's he's definitely happy with
this the knight can come to see 391 it's
not a happy piece but right 95 yeah well
I guess b7 is hanging like it is now
okay he goes for it and he'll give that
to take on c4 any day of the week
I think the main Gopher for white though
was that really getting that Bishop off
the f3 square was gonna allow him to
untie things here in a second he
actually thought he would go for this
because it kind of frees his position
even if he has to give an exchange at
some point yeah and here he's got to
maybe play Bishop to Bishop oh I don't
know actually it looks like he may be
regretting Knight a for right now and he
kind of shuffles and MBL's doing the
whistle right so uh so yes so yeah I
don't think this works said oh that did
not go so well okay just take the Queen
and yeah I think gonna take on a 7 so
you gonna take 187 no I thought you was
considering
but no of course not yeah nvl swindled
in there and I think I think white was
in the driver's seat should have settled
on on maybe just defending that Bishop
on BTU rather than the tactics of Knight
takes a four look at MDL now he's now
he's having fun he's singing music he
plays the Grob he's putting on a show
for the people and he knows it
he's smiling I see that that's yeah he's
really feeling it now well has it
necessarily gone well for Jeffery in the
second half of the match but what has
gone well is our beard contest on
Twitter hashtag speech has more more
beard submissions coming in the winning
beard Photoshop if you look up the
hashtags speech s you'll see it
Wednesday one year Diamond membership so
give me a beard that a mom would be
proud of everybody I think that's a good
idea then you're you're inspiring people
not to grow their own beards but to just
Photoshop it right I mean I feel like I
I feel like I deserve a beard like I've
been through enough you know so so the
beard is something that one deserves I
think so I think one deserves that
overtime you earned it okay through
trials of life because I'm trying to
earn this money of removing it yeah yeah
well urina you're enough you've always
been against the grain a little bit you
know we love that about you
alright well the the game is okay your
whites just a little bit better six
games it has to be okay with this I mean
weak bond on h3 if we had to
differentiate the two positions you'd
say there's a bit of weakness there but
white white has the activity of d6 and
f7 being potential targets yep
but again it's mostly just the time
situation and let's not forget this game
started with g4 so the garage for a
pretty decent position for white heads
Oh Grob the only thing that would take
this to the next level and I hope Maxime
doesn't do it because it may be a little
insulting for Geoffrey would be playing
the f3 king F to the the old bullet King
shuffle right but right max annealing in
the driver's seat here for sure but the
thing is you can't bring that out at
this point because it's 15 and
to nine and a half and that that can
swing more easily than people than
people think
yep yeah Jeffery used to win this one
here I think Maxime has gotten himself a
little bit of trouble there with the
rook so he backed up Jeffrey quickly
chop I don't like that at all I think
white is happy with this happy with the
transition yeah I don't know why he
allowed the h-bonds had become a jeep on
to become taken off the board so I think
white is just okay not not so much
better but just it's a bullet game so ya
know I think white is better I mean you
know even if it were a blitz game here
comes f4 okay I was thinking maybe a
four but he wants that for ya here he
wants that for there it is he's got a g3
can remove the rook now he wants Brooke
c2 again and he's just going to be kind
of shuffling back back and forth between
those squares rook see - now now Knight
f6 that's tough that was a tough move
everybody because if the King had moved
Knight f6 check was a fork on the king
and rook so he's gonna be trading the b7
pawn for the F pawn right the d6 pawn
comes with it and the d8 Square I was
gonna say good transition for white
because of that nice placement there he
goes to d8 maybe he would just go to c6
now and poke at the a 7th pawn possible
uh-huh well rookie 7 just wins the pawn
okay so he's a little better it's a
little better than that maybe as long as
he brings a one of his pieces back to
corral this Jeep on the rice connected
pawns should be the deciding factor he
tried to play Brooke a8 thinking he
could play 96 and go to the King upon
ending everybody but simply he's just
simply miscalculated to Tempe so okay
now this has become a bit of a game with
Maxime losing a critical tempo he might
you might be getting himself in trouble
with the cheap on but he's so fast he's
so fast here and Geoffrey the time the
time is taking and there goes the pond
okay as far as the X's and O's go you're
not super upset if you're Geoffrey but
the time is a factor but if you hold the
draw here I think you're happy if you're
if you're Geoffrey you can't take the
seat only a couple seconds and maybe one
like rook d4 doesn't work the time is so
low yeah still now can't take on d5 can
you or you can them and indeed you lost
on time
frustrating for Geoffrey wheels are
coming off a little bit you can see dad
behind him nervously watching over his
shoulder right no this is and you see
the H pawn by mvo he really is like a
very comfortable bullet player and and
what's what's this nonsense Geoffrey's
not getting the memo
you don't let the H bond reach h3 Danny
never never maybe that's a maybe that's
a generational thing that's something
that we know right maybe the younger
bullet players play a different style
bullet chess but yeah that's usually a
no-no just because it just causes so
much dysfunction to your Kings side
jokes aside it really is something they
normally you just play h3 and put the
put the brakes on that pawn but right
the maxime is is really kind of relaxing
now looks like he was checking his phone
for text messages he's singing he's got
the juice yeah he's comfortable she's
comfortable well it's too bad you know
Geoffrey really I think for the first
really almost two-thirds of the match I
don't think it would be a stretch for us
to say that Geoffrey played a higher
quality chess there you know he was he
was really doing well and then he poked
the bear he took the lead and really
hasn't hasn't hasn't had very many
chances since so yes his biggest mistake
was winning that game which sounds
sounds silly it's like so so why did you
lose the match well I won a few too many
games against India yeah I got him upset
but that's why I don't like I don't like
how this is has gone for him because I
think that he's still a little bit
focused on trying to play that the good
chest that he exhibited in the beginning
of the match whereas in the yellow he's
playing a 5 H 5 he's he's in bullet mode
and he's he's using the time and he's
just making stronger moves faster yep
and now he's got an attack which from a
practical perspective means again you
love
even if we don't see a mate right away
this bishop is super irritating and
Geoffrey is under the gun again he's
just got every move in advance like he
and he already sees the members and and
viewers watching the show are under the
gun to submit beard contest will move oh
it was beautiful I got distracted and it
blew my mind double-cross Bishop
checkmate what's that one called again
is that Damiano I forget I don't think
it's I don't think it's fat it's nice
cross criss cross I heard the name I
would know yeah some kind of I couldn't
look at the screen there I couldn't look
at my Karina I was looking at the beard
and that it's like everything happened
in slow motion double bishop checkmate
and I you know I almost blacked out I'm
glad I did that so this is a is this a
PG show Danny I thought I thought it was
it okay maybe let's tell MV all that in
the interview make sure he knows for
next time yeah really is that that mate
was yeah that mate that mate was rated X
goes right beyond rated are the the
matches is pretty much ready to be
called at this point I mean that's
really the honest truth everybody with
only eight minutes left and an eight
game lead problems but okay the young
the youngster came out ready to play he
was prepared some high quality chess to
start and just couldn't quite find
himself in the bullet it'll be
interesting to see what happens over
time because these guys will play each
other and other bullet matches that the
fans will see on chess calm not with our
commentary but I know Geoffrey is closer
to being equal with with Maxime here
although maybe maybe I'm wrong right I
mean everyone you know a karo tends to
feel that the gap is really huge between
the the elite elite and then a bunch of
other people that you know Geoffrey has
a high rating but he also probably plays
lower rated players than Maxime most the
time right ya know and the opinion of
someone like Nakamura in this case is
quite valuable because he has that
direct experience and I imagine he's
probably the best judge of Bullen
character that that that we have but
it's a shame that the final score is
likely going to be reflected
very one-sided match Wainwright honestly
she could have come out and been ahead
after the five two portion I don't think
anyone expected him to really hang with
MVL theoretically
in some of the most complex like nigh
Doris and Berlin's that nvl you know he
plays with Magnus and Kuryakin and
Nakamura like top guys in the world with
this stuff and Geoffrey's right there
with them so yeah I don't think the
score will be reflective of how close it
was but it really was MVL turning things
around in the three-two portion and then
bullet has just been kind of a show yep
and if we if we talk about the the
overall score of the match obviously you
see it this or a card in a little behind
here but let's talk about quick about
what's gonna happen in the bracket with
Maxime moving on after this match to
play Sasha crook a a rematch right
didn't they play last year no no brick
played Carlsen in the second that's
right
Maxime played Fabiano and want that and
then and then lost to a core oh I
believe but alright well we will have
Maxime Vashi lagravis Alexandre Creek
that's gonna be that's gonna be a crazy
match right there I mean I don't know I
don't know who I have favorite on that
one so yeah wait to see that as Maxime
is gonna move on here yeah I think that
that much is is clear someone in the
chat is saying it's kind of crazy that
in the the format of the speech has
championship there hasn't really been I
mean there's been upset games and upset
moments but there's never been an upset
match anybody that goes back to what I
was saying was as jeffrey takes a game
while while we're chatting
he gets guess one on the board for
himself but I think that's reflective of
the fact that as we were saying the
longer match just favours the better
stronger player yep the more games
played the more the more skill and
talent shines through but you know as we
we've seen really close ones we haven't
even seen an upset in terms of the I
mean upon Miyoshi Levon Aronian I mean
in my eyes I had Aronian as the favorite
there right but because of the seeds in
terms of blitz nepo
actually was the higher seat and won
that one so I think there's been several
I mean even the eight nine seed right
Geary versus so so you know I think I
think we're bound to see a higher seed
win at some point here but but you're
right yeah we we have seen no upsets and
and okay we we see a big win there by
Jeffrey but not gonna Bev enough time to
turn things around no we're pretty much
getting to the last couple bullet games
of this match
and speaking of bullet positions this is
a very nice one for MDL here although
definitely did slay h3 finally he did he
did he finally stopped the h1 I think
that was important but usually usually
any type of position like this with such
a massive attack is very close to just
crushing for black and I don't think
he's even calculating he's just playing
with instincts I'm sure this will be a
mate pretty soon yep it is rolling for
the Frenchman and we also have
commentary in other languages of course
Kevin bordey known as blitz stream is
broadcasting live on chest comms French
channel so a big audience there a huge
fan base for MBL obviously in France and
on chess calm but he's gonna be moving
on and in the in our bracket as you can
see now Maxine Boucher the grub will be
will be taking on Sasha Krisha updated
bracket there for everybody to put in
their memories before the show is over
yeah absolutely
I think that Jeffrey has to be a bit
content I mean I look forward to to the
interviews and got a lot of questions
for him especially on the out like how
how he really found Geoffrey because I
think most of the people who were in
mismatches going into the speech Chess
Championship like you said I think NBL
kind of got the hardest time he got the
youngest for arguably most talented
player around his age who's really good
in the online format so that's kind of
the toughest qualifier that you could
get your hand and I wonder if he really
felt like he was a massive favorite or
if he expected it to be this difficult
yeah well I know from talking to Maxime
in st. Louis I made a comment about how
he might feel this year with the side of
the bracket he's on moving on
he told me well you know I got to get by
Jeffrey first so I know I know there I
know how you know Maxime felt about that
lots of respect for the talent of mr.
young and the way the match started it
you know obviously I think at a certain
point Maxime was like okay I got to pull
it together we saw that happen you know
visibly on camera all the sudden he he
turned it on and and now he's continuing
to roll moving it back to an eight-game
lead with about two minutes left total
in the match clock this is likely to be
our last bullet game Maxine back above
3000 right in the a thousand club I
think we have Jeffrey he's resting his
hand on his head on his hand with one of
those like yeah at this point at this
point it's just a show that's right
but yes MDL is this reading still
provisional he seems to be jumping
around jumping around going up and down
quite a lot he's definitely deserving of
the 3,000 rating but I haven't I haven't
seen him play many matches yeah and and
lately he hasn't been playing as much on
Jeff's calm he's missed a few title
Tuesday's but for those who don't follow
max seems professional career it's
because he's played more games in 2017
so far than any other player in the top
ten I don't even know that it's close
Maxine has been everywhere he's been
everywhere he's played in like every it
seems like every candidates event like
he got his first three or four events
out of the way early you know he's just
played in every single tournament every
super tournament in Norway in st. Louis
he just won the Singh field Cup so so
Maxine vache the grove is is having
quite the 2017 so far and and continues
here so all right well the time is time
is about to expire and I've been told
according to the official match time not
even the one I have you guys here this
is definitely going to be the last game
even if it ended right away we would
probably start the chess960 game but
okay we'll see what happens here how
Maxime decides to deal with the c-file
pressure that Jeffrey is bringing yeah
barring a serious blunder it looks like
we'll have one more chess960 game and I
believe Jeffrey will will get white and
and then that'll be the last the last
game of the match which nvl will
definitely win at this point there's a
no-no type of math that can save him
here
nice work there yeah we're gonna see him
probably push this endgame to try to win
and the out but this is the last ball
game and I don't know if we have we ever
seen a clean sweep in the chess960 I
don't know maybe Magnus against
Petrossian last year but right maybe
maybe not but I'd have to I have to
check a stat stat guy stabbed boy mr. my
client had to step away so he's not here
hearing my every little request but
anyway I'm curious actually if Jeffrey
gets white again and decent chances to
win the chess960 game if we if we have
ever had a full sweep so alright well we
could learn something here in this last
bullet game there should be some
interesting technique I feel like
White's drawing chances are pretty good
given that he's established a decent
blockade on the white squares the knight
has this safe position yeah I think this
should be a fairly routine draw
especially because now you can just
shuffle like h8 g 6 and right just close
your eyes and do that simply simply
agree to withdraw and the chess960 game
has been started only a fool analyzes
Blitzen bullets ed Nesbitt Dean off and
only chest calm they play bullet
chess960 this is basically this is
basically you know the chest version of
Russian Roulette here I mean this is
like you just have no idea what you're
gonna get in bullet to play to play
chess 960 right and I was surprised that
both players didn't start by moving
their f-bombs because whenever you can
make a one move threat and chess960
always very tempting right we take say -
or queen takes a seven and is he gonna
do it again you don't pour it LVL like
some pawns this is a three didn't get
trapped it's not yeah this time the lady
is gonna is gonna get out same square -
so maybe he's having flashbacks PTSD but
okay Jeffrey can maybe can he take is
Jeffrey's rating 3000 is that his chess
960 rating going through the roof after
a couple wins against MVM yeah yeah
that's a he might be the highest rated
I'm sure the baby is actually yeah so
there you go he can take something away
maybe if he wins this this game will be
the undisputed chess960 champion that's
right well as certainly as far as this
match goes and although again it's just
kind of funny he did certainly did not
get the best chess960 from mvl again if
you're just joining us everybody you
missed I suggest you back up and check
out the five five move loss by the 2,800
Frenchman so yeah crazy stuff all right
but okay I mean I'd like to see him at
least take some solace in something if
you could clean sweep the chess960 that
would kind of be nice for him yep
apparently it has not been the first
ever sweep even if it happens Hikaru
this year went three you know in the
chest 960 against Sergei Grigoryants in
the first actual match of the year on
back on May 3rd so but this this looks
very much like a normal chess game now
I'm on I mean yeah it's transition
White's better but you know a normal
chess game position 95 5 95 was there
and it was 95 can I get it can I buy a
95 and it was still there 95 oh man Jeff
we could have put him away there
everybody we got to show that real quick
95 tactics right here even after King g6
95 was still good because the pawn on f6
was pinned to the rook so missing
missing a chance there by Geoffrey and
missing his chance to go 3 you know
really because if he played that it was
for sure a win he may still win right
right he's definitely the one pushing
here kind of a nice nice endgame he's
got with light-square clinic right AC
like what's up with this it seems like
he's he's a chess960 secret beast yeah
well yeah and he you know it's too bad
he missed 95 but it looks like he's
gonna go on to go to go to grind town
here and take this one home the PG
version because as we said it's this
Brook is actually trapped which is we're
gonna be four has nowhere to go
oh yeah fun he'll get its work out now
but here comes Knight h5 check ok or
Knight back to d5 and I think that
I can swing the rook over to the Kings
side and I even like rook c6 and rook c7
trade the ropes and just win that again
yeah just do work yeah he does that I
think that's the practical decision I'm
hoping that he can he can convert it
here it's times getting a little low but
this is definitely completely winning
here well the time is out as far as the
total the total match time remind
everybody that the the clock has run out
we will be grabbing the players for
interviews momentarily as soon as this
game is over be nice if if the youngster
can get a win I think he's gonna win
thank you I think you should be able to
brings the knight to the idea now the
night falls and it's over okay
next team didn't resign but we expect
that to happen here shortly
nice job okay
maxime leans back he's thrown in the
towel in regards to that last chess 60
game but the the match is over and
joining us now are both the players
Geoffrey and Maxine could you guys hear
us
Geoffrey you there yeah hi hi Maxime
waited waiting to see if Geoffrey I can
hear us yeah sure
yes I'm here now okay well first of all
thank you both for an awesome match it
was obviously I know that the final
score not not necessarily what you
wanted Geoffrey but it felt it overall
especially for the first 90 minutes of
the match the five-minute portion that
she came to play I mean you were playing
super high quality chess you hung with
Max Eames theory in both the night off
and the Berlin how did you feel things
were going heading into the three-minute
portion
well I think that in the 5-minute I
think I was fortunate that max I mean
mvl made I I don't think he was playing
his best in that time control and laid
around he started to find his for so I
think yeah and
in the end yeah the I guess connection
let me down Maxime was was it a bit of a
wake-up call when Jeffrey took the lead
at seven and a half six and a half at
that point you seem to kind of do a
shift in your chair and say oh I need to
turn it on well I mean to be honest like
Jeffrey said I think in the first few
games I was really struggling to find my
form and there were a few unfortunate
moves that you know made me in trouble
you know when I was looking for the
cleanest wins in some burdens and then
someone would end up getting worse or
even lost so yeah I think in the five
minutes portions vide I wasn't playing
my best
an indiscriminate yeah at first I wasn't
playing well and then I somehow managed
to wake up a bit so that was you know
necessary to to turn things around
because Jeffrey was putting up really
really great resistance and in one
minute portion I realized that you know
his connection wasn't doing so well so
you know that said that I wanted to ask
every okay how how he felt about the
night off because obviously that must be
a little bit of a theme for for this
this match Jeffrey did you prepare to
play like with and against the night off
quite happily for this match um yeah me
and nvl basically play the exact same
openings with black so I I decided to
see how how I would do in the night
wharf and it turned out not so great so
the games I played yeah you had you had
that really scary early game where
Maxine played this Knight takes e5 I
don't know Maxine if you have any
comments on that move but that looks
like a really big big shocker to us
honestly that looked like a novelty that
belongs in a edit over the board
tournament so how well did you know that
after Knight takes e5 but I did know it
but you know there's a couple of reasons
why and you know I felt it was fun to
play to play here yeah pretty good to
bring out in annex format not sure about
classical maybe it seemed though at some
point Maxime you kind of shifted you
shifted to mixing up a little more with
d4 were you were you impressed with
Geoffrey's play I mean obviously he had
he had several good Berlin positions as
black right and and seem to be doing
doing okay there so was it was it a
switch to kind of change things up and
decided that that he had kind of proved
himself on the black side of the Berlin
I feel like I was doing fine in many
buildings and then somehow you know with
one stupid move I would mess things up
and I felt like it it would be a decent
wing if d4 into the mix but not because
of any special preparation because I
just you know decided to do step away
from for me for a while Geoffrey the
coming in on paper you guys were very
closely rated in terms of bullet both
you guys are obviously two of the best
players and and bullet on line and it
just didn't seem like you you you felt
comfortable were you already a little
bit frustrated with your play to end the
three-minute portion do you feel like
that maybe had some hangover to the
bullet or did you just run up against
Maxime vache of the Grove and that's
once that that's what happens yeah I
think actually there was this one very
critical moment which was I think I took
the lead then I had white and I messed
up the opening but the game after that
it was some Italian and I think I was up
with pollen just better and I managed to
lose so I guess that was the turning
point and okay in the bullet I think and
they'll just he just sees things much
faster than me okay well one thing that
you did better than almost anybody in
our in our format history and obviously
better than Maxine today was the
chess960 Maxime
yourself with queen takes a to explained
yourself losing in five moves in that
first one I miss mayonnaise
what's inexcusable is how I lost the
second game because I'm like two pawns
up good attack so you know that was
frustrating coming in so short game
anything can happen of course I
shouldn't choose this but it's one
minute but is the second game I mean
pissed me off quite a lot well you're
just despite the score in the end
Geoffrey you are one of only two people
only Hikaru Nakamura has also gone three
you know in the chess960 portion against
his opponent so you you took all three
chess960 games today that's a small
victory despite the 19 to 12 final score
but Maxime you're moving on to play
Alexandre grishnack in the next round
and obviously a huge huge matchup there
between you and Sasha what do you expect
to happen there and how do you think you
match up with the Russian well it's
going to be fun because like Geoffrey
such a place the night off and when felt
on a regular basis so you know I mean
there might be some surprises but could
be it's some sort of night of Derby for
instance got it I mean it's gonna be a
really tough match and it's gonna be
very enjoyable okay well today was today
was really enjoyable for all of us so
thank you again to both of you guys as
we before we let you go here Aman do you
have any other questions I think mostly
just to Geoffrey like a well played
matched by Maxime of course and congrats
on the victory but Geoffrey did you feel
like you were as much of an underdog
maybe as some of the other mismatches
the chess talks on qualifiers would get
to play against some of the top players
in this tournament because we know
you're very used to playing online chess
which not everyone in this tournament is
and you also have very similar ratings -
Maxime and Blitzen bullet did you feel
like you were such a big underdog
because certainly from the Blitz it
seemed like you were very confident
starting
well I think in online I have a lot of
experience I mean I I was I've been
playing like since 2007 so I was just
online is now just very it's like home
for me
so yeah I felt pretty decent yeah yeah
well it showed and you played super high
quality chess and we know that in the as
the three minute portion transition
there we were joking that as soon as you
took the lead you poked the bear and
Maxine Maxine went on a tear from there
and and really really showed everybody
why he's he's a big favorite in this
overall format so and if we
congratulations for even being here
Geoffrey obviously won the qualifier
Maxime if you look back at all the
qualifiers was Geoffrey probably the
scariest qualifier to face given given
his his age and kind of you know comfort
online or how do you feel how were you
feeling heading into the match knowing
that you had you had gotten the the
Geoffrey pick of the four people that
qualified well to be honest I mean to
qualify there you you need some sort of
skills so you know I am I mean of course
it was a very tough match but I'm sure
that you know the qualifiers were also
very tough and you know I didn't really
think about it I just enjoy the format
enjoy and drug playing and yeah I mean
even though in the beginning itself like
and my head wasn't working properly as
soon as I got it going you know I was
having fun again right what we bought
music were you listening to some sort of
some sort of rock and what were
your snacks of choice cuz I mean
obviously these are the more important
questions you uh you didn't stop to
perchance some chocolate bars but yeah
we did about the food all right well
thanks again for both of you
a reminder to everybody as we let our
players go that the next speed Chess
Championship match is on October 5th so
we have a bit of a break for the month
of September basically due to the World
Cup good luck to you both Maxime and
Jeffrey into Blee see Jeffrey and
they're already there and
and Maxime I know you're headed there
soon yeah and we will see all the fans
again on October 5th before we let you
go we will say that we had a we had a
fun contest here with with the beard
winner the beard winner is gonna go to
we had a Photoshop contest mr. wool mule
wool mole on Twitter wins for the bowtie
beard a bond are you come on are you
approving of this winner
I haven't actually I haven't actually
seen it now I see it that's I'm honored
that there's a contest created around
putting my beard on your face apparently
right but hopefully I can be known for
something else - you know what being a
Grand Master will be pretty cool anyway
Maxime and Geoffrey thanks for staying
with us thank you both and again good
luck in Tbilisi as we let you go good
luck against grishnack in the next round
Maxime and Geoffrey will probably see
you next year since you win another
qualifier who knows maybe be seated yeah
thanks your day thank you guys
check chess is a game of unlimited
beauty but it's not just check stand
attacks you have to be creative
I'm here to share with you my knowledge
of the game of chess but I'm trying to
come up with the comprehensive picture
that will be helpful for you to become a
better chess player and even a better
decision that's covered 55 King c2 King
f6 can be sneaking g17c 14 to 16 before
King Cecil King gazing boom white lost
yes
Quinn takes and Knight f5 and it's
double attack skew and attraction and
it's mate but an amazing mate how can we
prevent this rook from stopping our porn
let's pause stop the video and see you
have time to find this winning
combination
did you see that it's your bishop
whether still you have Nazi no I
don't say that that's interesting so you
attack my mission then you protect your
vision right so let's go back and see
whether we can improve and what's the
next logical rules
[Music]
it's about coming up with new ideas
challenging your own excellence find
your mistakes next time you have a bet
I've been thinking about few ideas that
I never used one I want to show it's
another sacrifice
I'd like sacrifices and it's one of my
favorite obliques so just let's have a
look
we cannot waste time time is precious
if you don't feel that the game can
leash will create a potential then you
already
will lose your son it's not about
winning or losing and of course at the
end of the day it's about winning
I'm Gary Kasparov and this is my master
class